Wait a second.
Oh, that's the game.
And that's me.
Oh,
my windows are messed up.
There we go.
I think.
That's a bit better.
Maybe.
My, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my,
my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my,
Welcome in, welcome in, welcome in, wait.
Is that me or the kid?
That's me.
Not the kid.
I'm making sure that the size is not cut off a little bit on
the bottom.
Okay, anyway.
Whatever.
It's fine.
We're okay.
Domenclor.
I think that's a new one.
Hi.
Hello, Eve funds.
Oh, thank you!
Thanks, Murphy.
What do you think of Murphy for?
Mito-chan, kawaii-yata!
Thank you!
Oh, did you guys see my holy...
My Japanese has regressed so bad.
I can't...
Well, I also was so...
tired.
Jurassic!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Announced today on Ayami Mama's stream, we have Ayami to
Ayami family collab cafe!
Yata!
Yippee!
So, the collab We'll be running from the 7th to the 20th, I
think.
Pachi, pachi, pachi, I can't wait to go to you and a yummy
cafe again.
Yes, thank you.
So that was the gloop bloop.
Yes, it was.
And so unfortunately I can't put up the graphic right now.
But yeah, same place.
Gameplayers.
Hello, Minto, and I booze like you!
If the YouTube crashes, I fear you will have to stream via
carrier pigeon.
I will send to each and every one of you what I am doing.
How much Eve can we harvest from Minto?
Going to sleep!
I can't wait to watch the mod.
Good night!
Good night, good night.
Thank you, Brandon.
Good night.
What was I gonna say?
Oh, I meant to like...
Oh my god, okay, so...
I kind of mentioned this before, previous stream, but like,
I'm not used to these types of games, right?
Like, I don't do FPS very often.
They actually quite stress me out.
They actually quite stress me out, but... So I feel like...
Sometimes I'm like, I want to play, but I don't want to
play, you know what I mean?
It's not like me forcing... Well, it's a little bit me
forcing myself.
But, you know, at the same time I won't get used to the
games if I don't try them so you know it's kind of so you
know I've appreciate your patience with me as I as I tackle
Bioshock it's a pretty stressful game be brave Minto thank
you yeah especially because it's like a lot of switching
around stuff i i'm meant to practice a little bit um neil
good happy birthday words of motivation as i got final exams
in a few months i need some mentonium to survive this neil
you have everything you need and you and you you you you you
you you you you wait wait you wait the delay like just one
You!
It's not enough.
You can do it!
Do it!
Crank that.
I had it to 10.
Now I need to adjust my settings.
There's a ghost in the stream.
Happy National Chocolate Meat Day!
Actually, I don't know if it's a national fake meat because
I saw also a Japanese hashtag for...
I almost said national for Chocolate Mint Day.
So I think it is international Chocolate Mint Day.
Also, did you see the new Spinosaurus news?
Oh my gosh, yes I did.
Did you guys see that they discovered a different, like...
Species of Spinosaurus.
This guy has a bigger horn than the others.
It's like 20 inches long.
And he was discovered more inland.
So it kind of is like this guy, this guy isn't probably
searching for fish and stuff in the, you know, he's walking
around.
I don't know, eating bugs, who knows.
Yeah, new Spinosaurus.
New dino dropped?
I know.
We got the newest dino patch.
It's awesome.
Oh, facts.
Who cares about that?
Nerd, says Dr. Tyrannosaur.
Yeah.
You wouldn't.
Unicorn dino.
Come back next week for more Dino News.
Happy Chocobito Day!
I went to get new Costco chocolate mint Sunday and it was
delightful!
Truly, you are everywhere.
I want to try it.
You don't need to have a Costco membership to get the food,
right?
You can just walk on in.
I think?
Stream alerts off.
Oh, they might be...
Oh, sorry.
I had them off.
Hold on, one moment.
I turned them off for when I was recording.
Yesterday.
Oh, my gosh, you guys.
Also, Ducky, thank you.
Happy National Chocolate Minto Day.
Why can't I say chocolate normally?
I was recording Portal 2 yesterday.
And, oh.
I did the first one as a member.
stream then i did the second one off stream i'm i'm letting
you guys know it's rough
um part part six is is rough i i i don't know what happened
in my brain at all um i had a hard time on something that
was so it was so stupid i was like i don't know i don't know
i don't know Literally, I had to stop recording and take a
break.
And then while I was like sipping my tea, I was like, wait a
second.
Would if I, and then I solved it like in one shot right
after.
I was so angry.
So classic gamer.
Oh gosh, I almost wanted to like, it was so bad.
I had to do like a, like a five five time well yeah five
time zoom on it and it's 100 worth it for the cake i felt i
wanted to i wanted to scrap the entire thing and redo it i
was so angry i was like you guys are gonna be anybody
watching is gonna be like girl oh it's it's rough i'm
telling you now it's it's not an easy one
because I'm literally I think out of the hour that I
recorded actually I had to go over because I couldn't get
the puzzle it's like 45 minutes
so I was like oh I feel so stupid I don't know sometimes you
know things just like really click with you and sometimes
like Even if it's like a simple solution, sometimes the
brain just does not work.
Oh, geez.
Real ones won't skip.
No, it's okay.
You can skip.
I think I even put like a...
Actually, I put like a...
Uh-oh.
Sorry in advance for this room subtitle.
so much for the thank you thank you thank you
missing something so obvious that even guides don't mention
it is the most relatable experience i was just like i i was
like i don't know and then it was literally um so the puzzle
okay i'll just explain a little bit it's like a two-parter
puzzle i would say the first one part is quote unquote more
difficult than the second part and the second part is what i
get so hung up on i am i oh man it's rough it's 9 p.m of my
birthday here can i get a happy birthday master your ray
happy birthday happy happy birthday but anyway i'm stalling
a little bit because i am feeling kind of like i said i get
nervous with these games I just have to go in.
I'm gonna eat this candy.
It's called, That's what it's called.
It's a mystery candy and it's that's the name is, what is
this flavor?
It's red candy.
It's a quiz.
It just told me what...
I only wanted the answer to the quiz.
It's in the shape of a heart.
Oh, no it's not.
I only got half of it.
I thought it...
Netamare!
Okay, I'm trying.
I'll tell you, I'll taste it and then I'll tell you what
flavor it is.
Whoa!
I taste it.
This is a strange flavor.
Mon Buran?
Do you guys know?
Hold on.
Wait, it's...
How... I only know...
I don't think I've ever had it in English.
This flavor.
Mon Buran.
The chestnut.
Yes.
Montblat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that one, that one.
It tastes just like it.
It looks like like it would be like a fruity...
This is so strange.
Okay,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm stalling.
Blonde is white in French.
Yes.
But what is the moon?
The color of the candy is red, though.
She's stalling us from greatness.
I'm sorry!
Mountain.
Mountain of white?
Chestnut?
Isn't this a stalling stream?
It is, it is!
White mountain.
Petals of white, but a mountain.
Mountain of white.
You know what?
Some people call my cheeks that...
This is your part to say.
Which cheeks?
Let's start the game.
I'm going to get this out of my mouth.
It's okay.
I have the wrapper.
Reading good books lately?
No, actually.
I did get...
That's funny that you asked that because I got...
Oh, no.
I got rid of the notification.
I got a notification today that was like...
author uh uh that you've that you've read before put out a
new book we already know which ones yeah because my cheeks
are red because i'm blushing all natural what was it anyway
it was just like it was like it was like here's some some
book and it was called like hot hot piper or something no
hot piper okay how to play this game leaks lunatics
rebellion and now bleeding ghosts wait ghost oh yeah we have
seen ghosts oh where am I oh okay yes yes this is where we
start yes this is where we started who's talking though all
right hold on um all right this is the switch in between i
hear people over there um and then to go to look to go to my
magic how do i go to my magic oh shoot is it right click yes
and we have okay we'll do electricity right now.
Electric bowl.
Okay.
The one two punch.
Oh yeah.
Remember the one two punch.
That's this game CQC.
Okay.
Shift
is that.
Fontaine fisheries.
That's where we gotta go.
That's where we got to go.
I wonder what movies they were watching.
Oh, I can search the corpse.
Oh, I'll take that.
Yes.
Oh, I guess I didn't really need it.
Lots and sons.
Is anyone there?
Is that not a big, big daddy?
Our alert's still disabled.
What?
Wait, I turned them on one moment.
I know you're busy, but when you're able to check your
streamlight, oh, oh, oh.
Oh!
I didn't have the thing on.
That's my bad.
Oh!
We accidentally raised three times the amount needed for
your flower stand.
So here's the remainder.
We love you and are so proud of you and are looking forward
to whatever happens next for you.
Please use this for whatever cool projects you have in
store!
Thank you.
Wait, you guys didn't have to do this.
that though wait that's a really big that's a that's a
that's a really big amount thank you from i booze with love
we actually had to cut the fundraiser short
thank you thank you so much thank you so much holy moly holy
cow oh my god thank you thank you so much how much total was
that i'm afraid to say it because it's so much uh one one
one thousand seven hundred forty four dollars and fifty
cents thank
you so much thank you thank you guys oh my gosh i don't feel
like that it should have gone to me though maybe the people
get their money back you guys should have split it amongst
yourselves or something I do have the, um, I took home the,
the big, the big cards that were with the flower stand.
I have them.
I have them here with me, so.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
We love Binky.
Oh, now I gotta kill people.
An almost 2K smack-a-roo's hot dog!
Holy...
I will put to good use.
I will.
Yes.
Actually, yes.
Thank you so much.
Oh, hey.
Gene bank.
Oh, oh, okay, okay.
Take your money.
I have a lot of money, actually.
Oh, it's this thing.
The Vita chamber.
Okay, good.
good where actually do i go from here though looking around
oh i have my pointer oh i gotta go over there okay just
kidding but first hot dog couple thank you welcome to little
circus of values all right i gotta get back into the hacking
too let's hack oh wait uh how do i do this again
Uh, uh, oh shoot, wait, this one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, and, uh, uh, oh, nice, nice.
Uh, like, kind of nice.
Oh, shoot.
I'm, like, looking around.
I can see if I can find the things I need, like you!
And you.
Okay, woof.
We inspired so many cosplays, thank you!
My feed is so many cosplays of me!
It's kind of crazy!
It's kind of insane.
Result of successful hacky.
Let's see what we got in here!
Of value!
I have a lot of money.
I feel like I should get some Eve.
Eve.
Now I have that.
Now, swap.
Oh.
Oh yeah, first aid kits also give you Eve.
I forgot I had that one.
That one's awesome.
What is this?
Engineering tonics.
Improve your ability to interact with the machines.
Spend that money.
I bet Eve tastes like blue raspberry.
I agree.
It's blue drink.
I have this telekinesis.
Wait, I thought I had a fire, wait.
Oh, here we go.
Incinerate.
Set objects and creatures on fire.
I think I wanna switch it out for that.
I don't know, I feel like I use these, you know.
Don't wait, incinerate.
It's free, right, to swap out?
Oh yeah, oh yeah, baby.
You have an empty slot that you could put, wait, I do?
What do you mean?
Oh, like here?
And I don't have anything else.
Don't lie to me.
There should be a mod that says, Feel Good after the circus
of value laughs.
Oh, feel good.
YouTube was censoring feel plus good together.
YouTube being more D-Gen than...
What?
That's crazy.
YouTube doesn't want your health.
All right.
This is to switch.
Let's get my gun out.
Put your gun, Ty.
Alright, alright, I'm gonna stop being a little baby now.
I'm scared though.
This game stresses me out.
I'm not gonna lie.
I mean, I know you guys have been saying that.
It's a stressful game.
Is that it?
Wait, I can't go back?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, yes I can.
What if I'm too scared?
Look at all my...
Saves though.
I'll keep doing these because the game might crash.
Anyway.
I gotta remember how to play this.
91 days since our last accident.
Accidents last year.
Accidents this year.
2.
And a half maybe.
Oh my gosh.
The decor.
I'm surprised this guy isn't getting Ian by all the fishies.
Maybe he's nasty.
I don't believe this counter.
Something about it seems false.
What the?
Who was that?
Safety is everyone's responsibility.
A friend.
They're always friends.
Wait, there's something shimmering up there.
Nothing?
Stingy?
Okay.
Alright, we keep going.
Wait.
What the days go by like wind?
Cool.
Oh, this is where the baby!
This is where...
This is where Little Sister crawls through.
Oh, gosh.
How many...
This is Rapture.
The wonders of Andrew Ryan will change your life.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Not a horror game, by the way.
Totally not a horror game.
Oh, let me...
Save.
Yeah, alright.
Do not turn off the computer.
And we'll hack it.
Uh...
Uh,
we're zigzagging.
We're zigzagging.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Zigzagging.
Wait, uh, there we go.
Easy.
I don't need to heal though.
Oh, did it get smokier in here or is it just me?
Just me?
Wait, is it getting really smoky in here?
Wait.
Are we out?
Oh!
I think she was looking at me.
Ooh, that ain't good.
Lower wharf.
Mccrack and crabs.
You gotta really love seafood to live here, huh?
What's that over there?
Oh, are you coming back?
Why?
Those are fish over there.
Oh, the girls are fighting.
Yeah, do it for me.
Oh, yeah, do it for me.
Oh, I think he died.
I think he's dead.
Hurry, Mr. Bubbles!
We're fine, right?
As long as I don't attack, everything's all good, right?
Right?
Anything in here?
Wait, what's that?
What's that meter?
What does that meter mean?
Do you guys see that?
Wait, is that his health?
Oh.
You remember this?
What's that mean?
I'm scared.
What does that mean?
You remember this.
Yummy.
Oh, I shouldn't have eaten them.
Hello?
Mr. Bubbles.
Is this a thing, though?
Oh.
Somebody has a...
Um...
I don't know if I got him.
Oh, oh, oh, I thought I heard somebody behind me.
Wait, oh, this thing is gonna take off again.
yeah yeah yeah okay i forgot it's not it's not manned maybe
who's talking to me hey oh you oh my gosh out out out out
out out we're fine we're not fine nothing's fine okay all
right i gotta i gotta get it and then i gotta go hack it
okay Did I get it?
Maybe I did?
Yes I did.
Nice.
Hack, hack, hack.
Wait, what did this do?
What the hell?
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
No hint.
Hack!
Oh, hack.
Oh, it's really hard.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
The H came up and it was like, are you stuck?
Dummy?
H for hack!
Alright, save.
Okay.
170.
Okay, hack, hack, hack.
Okay.
Alright.
I have a question.
Can they, like, I can hack them, but can they, like, reset
them, like, to be evil turrets?
Or are they forever friendly?
Gamba.
No, all yours.
Oh, cool.
Alright.
Oh shoot.
I'm already feeling the pressure.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, no!
Ow!
Wait.
I'm feeling the pressure, Mr. Crabbs!
Mr. Crabbs!
I don't like this!
Mr. Crabbs, I don't- Oh, shoot.
What the hell?
Okay, I think we're gonna lose this.
Uh, yeah, we got- we don't have this.
Okay.
Wait.
No, no, no bots.
No bots, no bots.
No bots.
That would be stupid.
I have finger on V.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, I don't think this one's as difficult as before.
Maybe.
I say that.
I will surely regret saying that.
Oh, oh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Uh...
I just need...
Yeso!
Oh!
Okay.
Oh my
gosh!
Yeah, get him turret!
Get him turret!
Where are you?
Where'd he go?
Get him turret!
I traded you, O Lord, for Mammon.
Come on then!
You come on!
Where are you?
Oh shoot.
Oh stop!
Stop!
You're a very... you're a very very good turret.
You're a very good turret.
Am I a good turret?
Oh.
Oh no.
Big Daddy's coming.
Oh geez.
Okay, wait.
Uh, can I hack this?
That did almost kill me.
That would have been wild.
What's in here anyway?
A Valias.
Only if I hack it, I can get the Eve.
Where am I going?
Oh my god, wait, is he like stalking me?
I'm scared, I'm so scared.
Ooh, this is freaky.
Enter the code.
I'm... I'm...
Trapped, I think.
Surely he won't come down here.
Whatever this is
There's something up there even You can hack it Oh you can
Oh you're right I didn't even say that Oh my gosh I don't
even see how tough it is Holy thank you so much for the
fight Get the thank you Okay it's a medium
There we go It's like can I get a thing please
Is it safe to be in here?
It's my eyes.
Nothing is in the smuggler's crate.
Are you kidding me?
Oh, my eyes.
Timmy.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Give me my taste, Patrick.
What's that?
guys oh my gosh my eyes i'm so sorry okay legit question do
you think big daddy can fit through this door please no
thank you thank you so much do you think if i is this timmy
i don't want to look at him because it's so my eyes yes he
could You think I could just stand here and shoot at him?
Oh, man.
Oh, I'm in the water.
I'm an idiot.
Okay, wait, hold on.
Let's...
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, my gosh, this game.
Where did that person come from?
Can you go through here?
Where did they come from?
Oh, they got cash money, though.
Oh, these fish.
We're remembering how to play the game, everybody.
Oh, that's not him.
Can I get up there?
There's something up there, though.
Oh!
I collected bugs.
Four of them, I think.
There's something else over there.
Maybe he's...
He's gone.
There was something shining.
Oh, there.
A lot of machine gun rounds.
Wow, okay.
Anything up there?
Wait, there's more under here.
Fab.
All right, I save and then we go.
Whatever this game can do, men can do double.
RJ, hey on happy birthday!
Happy happy birthday!
I'm just gonna go.
Where is he?
He sounds so close.
Why isn't my rocket working, huh?
Did I search this guy?
Yeah, oh, no I didn't.
He had two bucks.
Oh, there he is.
They're spawn camping me.
What?
So, if I get too close, they become hostile.
Is that the case?
If I shoot or get too close, right?
Yes.
Okay.
I don't know quite yet how close is close.
This is not a super great place to attack him, I feel.
So, I am...
What is that sound?
What is that?
Why isn't my rocket working on him, huh?
No, I don't need a hint, please!
I'm scared!
Don't come over here.
This guy looks different.
This helmet looks a little different.
I'm not, I'm not.
Holy cow.
Oh geez!
That's a turret.
I had a feeling it was a turret.
Of course it's a turret.
is he coming back this way don't you dare why you're you're
you v v i can't be ah i'm
shooting at nothing ouch did i make it somehow somehow in my
life spray and pray i was i was literally spraying like this
because of the god no was shooting like that.
What is that right there?
I wish I could have hacked it.
I tried.
I tried to get to it.
How do I switch the different ammo's again?
The recoil was crazy.
Oh, zapping it.
Yeah, that's right.
I can do that.
Where is the other one?
I don't...
Didn't see where it was at.
What a waste.
Ouch!
Where is it?
I don't see the other...
Oh, good, it's killing people.
It's also killing people.
Somebody else just left.
I don't know where the other...
Is he dead?
I don't have any more.
Do you have any?
What's that blue down there?
Is that the good stuff?
Oh, it's not the good stuff!
Um...
Guys?
Guys!
Crouch?
Wait, how do you crouch?
Because- Oh, see.
I can't hack it.
I got something, though.
Oh, here we go.
Okay, alright, alright, alright, alright, alright, sorry.
Getting back into it, getting back into it.
This is actually not a bad spot, isn't it?
This is actually a decent, okay, spot for you.
I hate these things, though.
Um, oh my gosh, really?
You're gonna be so rude like that?
Um, can I have a, like, one that goes the other way, please?
This, you.
And, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, oh, wait, I don't have a thing that
goes the the other way?
Wait, wait, this is so... Wait!
How am I... Wait, how am I supposed to turn it?
Um... I can't even loop it!
Oh, I was right there.
Oh, there was two of them.
I missed it.
My bad.
Um...
Wait.
That was my bad.
Oops!
Blind minkey!
Meow.
That's me.
All right, hack it.
All right.
Uh...
Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
Ah-huh, yes, yes, yes.
I see, I see.
Oh, uh...
I see.
Now I need you.
And I need you.
And we're finished.
Yippee!
Shinomi Kat, happy birthday!
Hacking is so hyper.
It's so fun.
Actually, I'm obsessed with this part of the game.
I don't want to waste it all.
I'm obsessed with the hacking.
I think that's a lot of fun.
Oh, I think that's more evil.
I wish I could
I wish I could hack it
Yeah, what was that?
I feel like I'm in a shootout I want to hack it, but I don't
know if I can reach Okay, hold on Let's see if my magic can
reach it
I don't think it can Let me try, let me try.
Is it that?
Yeah, I think I need to get closer.
Who are- the girls are fighting!
What are they- The girls are fighting!
Wow, if you guys are shooting at each other!
All right, girls.
Let's settle down.
Oh, what's this over here?
What are you?
Oh, a shotgun.
Okay.
There's a lot of stuff under here, isn't there?
Just random things.
How do I get out of this?
Wait until...
Go!
Oh!
Okay.
Oh,
man.
Oh, maybe I can leave this way.
Oh, my God.
There's...
Ouch!
Oh, God.
Oh, there's so much shooting!
There's a med kit on the ground.
If I could get anywhere, everything is just shooting all at
once.
Oh, my God.
Oh, he's a...
blast watching people play this game for the first time.
Counselor, thank you so much.
I can't.
Go away.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Of course.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
I'm trying to do anything right now.
I'm actually struggling to get out of here.
Oh my god.
This is tough.
This is a tough.
This is a tough...
I wish my turret could handle the other turret.
You know what I'm talking about.
Alright, book it boss.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm ready.
In 3, 2, 1, go.
I'm not... Why am I still crouching?
Run!
Oh, uh...
Ouch!
Everything's fine.
Everything's not fine.
At least he's got money.
Let's just get out of here.
Let's just... Let's just go.
I'm out of bullets.
I'm out of...
I'm out of everything.
It's just shooting.
Everything is just happening.
Why is there still more?
Oh, first aid kit.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, I'm up here.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I can just hear everything.
I'm not drinking that.
Let's hear, though.
A pistol.
Take that.
Gene bank.
Oh, okay, okay.
I just hear...
everything.
Oh, I went in a big circle.
Wait, are you serious right now?
I just noticed.
I went in a big circle.
It is so loud.
Oh, B to switch ammo.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Increases your maximum.
If I could have anything.
Plasmid slot.
Extra nutrition.
You gain a little extra health from snacks and bandages.
Try not to backseat, but if you die in the game, just
respawn a Vita chamber with no penalties.
Just in case you get stuck again.
Thank you!
Thank you.
No, you're good.
Like I said, I'm not used to these types of games, so they
stress me out.
Maybe reduce all physical damage would be really good.
Freeze your foes.
Wait, winter blast sounds awesome.
Wait, there's so many.
Hacker's Delight.
Every time you hack something, you gain a little health and
Eve!
Wait.
I think I need that.
I'm hacking everything.
I think Hacker's Delight would be the best thing ever.
You can freeze turrets with it too.
Speedy Hacker.
Reduces flow speed.
Wait, I kind of love all these like little eyes.
upgrades.
They're so fun.
I'm gonna hack.
Where is it?
Hackers delight.
Gimme, gimme, gimme, gimme, gimme.
Reduces difficulty when hacking turrets, bots, accounts.
Hack the planet!
Increases damage you deal to cameras, bots.
Oh, increases damage.
If I punch them.
Yeah, little hell.
I don't have anything that's like a Oh my god, they're still
shooting They're still going
I hear something I think I hear big daddy Yeah, this one By
engineering tonics Press to review the ones you have
currently equipped I don't have any Physical tonics But did
you see any engineering ones That we could have gotten
By the one that kills you instantly Okay
Hacking upgrades are off the engineering.
Well, not that one.
Unfortunately.
Okay, um...
I am slightly lost, though.
Goal.
Wait.
Oh, God!
They're coming back.
Go make this harder than it needs to work.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Okay, let's see.
If I crouch and go, well, it's CB.
Alright.
I think I'm going to try and hack it, the other one too.
Lateral.
Alright.
I'm going to run.
I get it.
Run!
ZIGZAG!
We're hacking?
I'm saving.
Oh, I'm hacking!
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all
right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all
right, all right, all right.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
what did I just do?
On Axia?
Yes.
Give me housing!
Give me eggs!
All right, we're done shooting now, right?
We're done being annoying.
I see something glow in there.
Looks like machine gun round.
My tummy's full, Mr. B.
She's so cute.
Time for a nap, sleeping.
Where is he going?
I think they went through that door.
Yeah, there they go.
Awesome.
Whoa!
Medical expert.
Your first aid kits will go further.
Healing sickness and injury at a rate you're sure to find
astonishing.
Oh no, I can't.
Wait, uh, first aid kids give you slightly more health.
This one is the first aid kids give you Eve, and this is...
Yeah, I think I should...
Why have you forsaken me?
I am.
Yes, my turrets!
Oh, how do you know I'm here?
Wait, how do you know I'm here?
There's a lot going on.
Okay, anyway.
Let's take all their stuff.
Holy!
You're loaded.
First aid kit.
What does coffee do?
Brittany.
Okay, I am lost.
I don't have very many pistols.
Yippee!
Okay.
What's that?
More?
More pistol?
Okay, actually killing them is pretty nice because you get
more stuff, right?
Oh, yeah, baby.
Okay, okay.
Alright, I'm saving, sorry.
Oh, yeah.
Actually, drinking...
Coffee gives you the Eve.
Oh, okay, cool, cool.
So it says we need to go this way.
Can I search you?
You know?
This way.
Is it...
Can I go back this way?
Does this open?
Oh my god, it opened this entire time!
Oh, that's a lot of first aid kits now, isn't it?
I didn't even notice this door.
My bad.
saving again this is the way this is it we got it we didn't
need no hint i'm good game one day the gentlemen start
calling i'm gonna hack this machine now please don't attack
me oh oops
please don't attack me madam
oh my gosh getting the hack thing is awesome.
Minky with a blicky.
It's a buckshot shotgun.
Saving twice before moving on.
She's just like me for real for real.
I'm glad that you can understand that.
Is that another first aid kit?
No.
That looks like a plug in the wall.
Wait.
What's all this though?
Oh no.
We're about the boss fight for real aren't we?
Wait.
Oh and they give us this.
Okay, we're in trouble, I think.
Rise up, save scum gang.
Yeah.
It's also because I'm like, I don't want to redo stuff if I,
like, if the game crashes.
I'm more save scummy.
Knock!
I'm more save scummy on games that I have to, um, that I
have to...
be careful about, you know.
All right, here we go.
Knock, knock!
Peach!
You're looking for an invite to the fisheries.
Nuts, I say.
But if in your heads up to the Warp Master's office and find
old Peach on research camera, maybe I could manage an
invite.
Oh, you're safe?
Well, what was that?
My friend, you are fucked.
Holy!
Oh!
Where did she go?
Oh my god!
No.
It happens to the top for you.
Look on the top of the belt.
You'll find something to keep you alive.
Now, go get that camera and then step shots of those that
crawls on the ceiling.
Then I'll let you into the fisheries.
Okay.
Grenade launcher!
I'll snap a ounce of fountain on you and I'll have you in a
box.
Atlas gives you the vouch, but I ain't turning my eye just
on his say-so.
Okay.
Woo!
Yes, sir.
Alright, well, that could have been worse.
Oh, that's big doubting.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
I saw PTSD from the noise the spider slicers make when they
scuttle about.
What?
thinking this is something, but it's our turret.
Alright, so we have to go get the camera from the...
Oh, sorry.
I'm trying to, like, get used to switching back and forth.
Oh!
There's guys down there.
Oh my god, There's three of them!
Wait, hold on.
Uh, yeah.
I thought that would kill them.
Let's let my turret take care of it.
I think it took care of them.
I think he's coming back.
I don't get one shot by that anymore.
It out!
Little sister.
She's so cute.
But we took care of him!
Word.
Oh yeah baby, oh yeah baby, oh yeah baby!
What else do we have here?
Electric book.
I didn't get that before.
Wait, didn't I hack this?
I thought I hacked this one before, no?
I thought I thought!
Oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez.
Oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez.
Oh yeah.
This one's tough, okay.
Um, can I get one that goes up?
Like this?
Yes.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
feel a little bit better now, bro.
I was like, I don't know if I'm going to make this one.
And, uh, oh, wait, here we go.
And then, where's the other way?
This one.
Okay.
Oh, maybe I didn't.
I think, okay.
Yeah, I guess I didn't.
The circus of value.
I will buy another Eve.
I want to buy another slot, to be honest.
Holy cow.
They explode so much, they just explode once they die.
Atlas, wait, what'd that guy say?
I didn't hear.
Unlock a plasmid slot.
Oh, this is the atom!
I forgot it's a completely, totally different currency.
That's right.
Nice shot, thank you.
By lots of Eve.
Oh, this is open now.
Oh, okay, cool.
Ah!
Oh!
Nice.
The fire does help.
The fire is scary, but it does help.
It's very scary.
Why are you empty?
Yes.
Nice.
Did I grab that?
Oh.
Gosh, there's so much stuff on the ground.
The game feels generous right now.
I have a feeling.
That will change in the future, huh?
Oh, is there a...
Where does this go?
Oh, this is a scary What the shooting?
What is that?
Oh, it's a tape gun.
Oh, I think those are my turrets that are shooting.
How
does this happen?
Rapture is transforming before my eyes.
The great chain is pulling away from me.
Perhaps it's time to give it a tug.
Give it a tug.
Perhaps.
Like, the turrets are doing their jobs out there.
Um, is that?
Hello?
Thank you?
Did that fall out of your pockets?
Wait, what?
Oh, I got him.
Oh, dang it, I couldn't get him.
Where did Bank tribute to the gutter goes?
Why did he do that?
I'm actually so confused why he did that.
I mean, I'm not gonna be upset about it.
I'm just confused.
Okay.
He's like, here you go, buddy.
You look thirsty.
Okay.
Yeah, he helped you out, yeah.
He did help me out.
He repaid him with bullets.
Actually, guys, I have to use the little ghosty's room.
I'm sorry.
I will be right back.
There's three little sisters in this level.
Maybe that's why I'm seeing them loop around so much.
Oh, my goodness.
We need to get the item.
We need to get the island.
I'll be right back.
I just gotta be.
Be every safe travels.
Yes, it is a treacherous journey that I must take to the
ghosty's room.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
We also grabbed some migraine medicine.
Okaidie.
I still have been having this one headache behind my my eye
my one eye and it comes and goes
where does it go I don't know I've had this for like the
past month or something like thought maybe maybe it's just
like because i have so much going on my stress is like
so all right let's keep going i'm not stuck maybe i'm stuck
in this grate a little bit all right um let's go i think i
just saved so
upper wharf upper wharf nothing what is this oh we're we're
hacking
wait oh yeah i'm hacking
i need a thingy yo
there we go easy peasy hey i'm into an eyeball it's my
birthday okay
recommend an eye pressure check i just got one recently so i
don't know maybe i need another one how many saves have you
saved altogether we're not counting are we counting we're
not counting are we are we counting we're not counting who's
counting not me I don't know how to count what is this whoa
cool oops a daisy oh geez little sister Nothing in the
trash?
That is the trash, right?
I'm not saving.
I mean, counting?
Yeah, yeah, I'm saving.
Proximity mine?
These are new.
What?
That's new?
I'm not saving.
You're saving.
Wait, how do I use the...
the...
Frat grenade.
Be the switch ammo.
Yeah, yeah, I do remember that.
I knew there would be a little sister.
Uh, they're not gonna get mad at me for that, are they?
Yeah, we're building them free.
Oh.
Dang it.
Oh no.
My last mod got copyright struck, so...
Ordin, thank you!
You're not mad at me, right?
I protected her.
Yeah, I protected her.
Oh, I was gonna get caught again.
I'm gonna get struck so bad.
That's okay.
I can't pick anymore!
Uh...
I saw one of these smugglers having a game of catching on
the docks today and these surprised me because his hands
were crippled during the war.
He was unloading the barge the other day.
Oh, I did a joke.
He was beaten from the sea slug.
He woke up the next morning and he found he could move his
fingers for the first time in years.
One second.
I think we gotta fight this guy.
I think we might need to fight him.
If I, like, can I hurt the little sisters, you know?
I don't want to.
Oh, this is the proximity mine.
Okay, okay.
Very cool.
No?
Okay, they're invincible.
Okay, cool, cool.
Wait, uh...
exploding buck oh my god
did i get his ass no i don't think i did
oh we were so close
whoa whoa no i'm not going no i don't want to go all the way
back there wait uh this one right oh she oh she Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
That wasn't bad.
Read like a book.
I know that.
Wait, wait.
Wait, where the heck am I?
Wait.
Huh?
This one.
That's the one I just did, right?
Oh, I gotta scroll up some.
There we go.
That was weird.
That many saves.
Shhh, shh, shh, shh, shh!
Wait, uh...
Uh...
Because his hands were crippled during the war.
Oh, okay.
He could move his fingers only for his power and force him I
don't
know if this works at all
No, it's not dream time Oh,
he's almost there
What is this?
What is going on there?
I'm afraid to get close.
Is it like a mine or something?
Oh, dang.
That's a mine.
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
Walk closer.
Little baby!
Give me the atom.
Thank you.
Armour piercing pistol rounds!
Gotta use those for a second.
What's the reward deal?
The reward will be inside a teddy bear at a gatherer's
garden.
Oh, let's go.
Yippee!
Alright.
Okay.
Wait, that's not what I meant to do.
We'll keep these for now.
F1.
That's what it is.
Okay.
I hear another one.
I hear another girl.
She's talking.
Okay.
I'm gonna save again.
Sorry.
We gotta reward!
Alright.
So, chill out.
Oh, it's the way... Oh, we're upstairs.
I just noticed where we are.
We don't know what has happened to you.
Ryan's men have taken you away and said you are needed to
save corruption.
Another guy.
I need a child to save a city.
But I see these little girls crawling out of these vents.
And I only wonder if you might one day crawl out of this
vent and find these not.
My baby is...
crawling out of the vent.
Oh, seven.
Seven.
Seven, five.
Oh, it's so sad.
We gotta run.
Eat the potato chip.
Okay.
I'm trying not to get got by the, um, by the rocket launcher
and also by a person.
Oh my god!
We're hacking?
Okay, all right, all right, all right, all right, all right,
all right, all right.
Sheesh, oh.
Oh, wait.
Wait, where did I put that?
Oh, actually this works.
This actually works.
you are finish hacker mint oh yeah
i'm gonna save again sorry i know i actually i'm saves
coming but i wish that didn't take so long to save i wish it
was like a moments thing i honestly just don't want to go
through everything again i
thought i saw something else shiny on the floor maybe not
i am to go into here.
Warning.
High security measures enforced beyond this point.
Central station monitoring and videotaping 24 hours a day.
I lack.
Can I shoot these?
Or...
Where am I anyway?
Oh, we're getting to the goal.
Whoa!
Good Goodness gracious!
Too many machine gun rounds.
Give me all your money.
Bozo.
What is this?
The bot shut down.
That sounds like a good idea, no?
We shall save before we do that.
Yeah, the camera.
Surveillance camera.
bot shut down.
Can I do it?
Does it work?
Can I hack it?
Hello?
What is this?
Bot shut down panels are used to cancel active security
alarms and shut down any security bots that have been
summoned by the alarm.
Using a bot shut down panel costs $20!
Okay, let me pay.
Let me pay the fee.
How do I use it?
Hello?
I wish to pay the fee.
Dude, the security cameras not count as active bots?
Oh, it has to be an alert.
What's going on?
Alright.
How?
I can hack it.
I just need to see where it is.
Oh, geez.
Uh, I can't hack it.
I'm lost.
Alright, wait, I'm stuck.
You don't see me?
Okay, good.
I'm too short to get it.
I have to jump.
Hut!
Oh, geez.
Hack!
There is no...
Okay.
Wait, I'm just gonna...
Hold on.
I'm gonna reload so that I can...
Oops.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna grab the stuff.
And I'm gonna...
This is too familiar.
This is too familiar with my everyday afterlife.
We can destroy it.
This is true.
There's also stuff like here.
I don't know if it will see me.
Honestly, I'm not quite sure, but I'm not risking it.
This Fontaine fellow is somebody to watch.
Once he was just a menace to be connected at home.
But he always manages to be where the evidence isn't.
He's the most dangerous type of huddle.
Kind with vision.
Something up there.
Can you guys remind me who Fontaine is again?
I am struggling to remember.
It hasn't been shown yet.
Also, there's something shiny over here, too.
Awesome.
What is up that?
What is all that up there, anyway?
What is up, dog?
I hear him coming.
I want to hack this.
Alright, so we can destroy...
Alright, once it goes back...
Okay.
Uh, oops, I couldn't see it.
That was my bad.
Wait, can I?
Nothing much.
How about you?
Hmm.
Didn't she have telekinesis?
I don't have it attached right now.
Freaky.
Oh, he's wearing his little mask.
Cute.
Okay, I'm just gonna go for it.
Okay, um, I know I can stand underneath and it does not see.
Yeah!
All right, now time to see what the other camera does.
Well, this one's even trickier, maybe.
Wait, uh, save!
Hack!
Save, then hack!
All right.
All right, we got this.
We got this team.
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Um.
We saved it.
We saved the run.
Nice save.
Holy cow.
Okay.
All right.
We're in here.
nothing in the smugglers
how far does this go feels a little far no
rag grenade wait does this go with my oh okay yes yes yes
alright perfect how much if I reload this 6 okay cool we
love to see it alright what sucks is I'm gonna have to come
back through here, you know?
This won't see me, right?
It will, it will, it will, it will!
Holy cow!
Okay, okay, I get it, I get it, I get it.
I want to hack it so bad.
I wonder if I can get it from a different angle.
You know.
Grab whatever that is.
I can't shoot.
I'm stupid.
Can I get it from here?
No, there's no way.
Anyway, let's just keep going.
I don't want to keep wasting Eve.
Warfmaster's office!
Okay.
Fancy sounding.
I'm sure glad I am.
Oh!
Alright, good to know.
I'm running.
Wait, what the alarm was going off?
From where?
From who?
Why?
Why was an alarm going off?
Six grenades, more than enough to kill anything that moves.
Through the glass.
Oh, I see it now, I see it.
Oh my gosh, that's tricky.
Okay.
the room.
It is sneaky.
And I heard a lady.
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
Oh, dang it.
I didn't want to lose more Eve.
I forgot that alcohol takes the Eve.
Is he coming from over here?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Can I please move?
God!
Everything is happening.
All at once.
What the heck is that?
Okay, okay, okay.
This is fine!
Oh!
I'm trying to decide what I want to go to.
first you know let's run past this okay which one got me oh
sorry
all right what i'll do is um oh there's that big daddy right
there no it's not no it's not no it's not
He says as he groans.
I heard him go.
Oh my god.
Alright, alright, here we go.
Oh my god, and there's a camera!
I gotta hack- This is not good.
This is actually the worst it could be.
I'm glad I just saved.
This is pretty grim, guys.
As soon as I am done with this, what do I do?
As soon as I'm done with this, what do I do?
Oh my god.
No, you.
I'm gonna press F and then I'm gonna look up and press V.
It's fine.
I just say it.
if it all goes to hell which it kind of is at the moment
which it kind of is already happening shoot
whoa straight shot nice yeah I hacked the camera first
my own turret's gonna kill me my own turret is going to kill
me my own turret is going to kill me see you maybe i kill it
i'm just gonna say it no don't load it news it oh my turret
my turret loves me so much it doesn't know how to love
without hurting me
oh wait i i was like wait a second i need to watch out for
one more thing don't oh you're dead no you're fine what's in
here oh this is like evil okay
so this is like really evil isn't it That didn't alert any
guards now, did it?
Oh my gosh.
Nothing here.
A crawler.
Don't find me.
Is this room safe?
Oh, we have a thing!
Oh, find a chamber!
Wait, this is not safe.
Gene bank.
I don't know what is shooting anymore.
Use the wrench in those vents.
Oh, okay, got it.
Thank you.
Wait, but my prize!
She said I have a prize.
At the next...
At the next garden!
Come on.
Use your legs.
You can do it.
I can't tell if there's a door to it over here or not.
Maybe it's through the vent.
That's what I'm thinking.
So far I'm okay with the things that I have.
The electricity is like nearly a must.
That sounds really close.
This sounds really close.
More machine?
This game really wants me to use the machine gun, huh?
Interrogation room.
Jesus loves me this I know.
Oh, I found it.
Oh, the Bible tells me so.
Little ones to him belong.
They are weak, but he...
Thank you.
Camera obscura.
Oi, did I see this room before?
Oh.
Hello?
Oh, there was a coffee.
Sure?
I'll... sure?
Okay, let's take it.
Take pictures of enemies at the camera to research them.
Each type of enemy has a unique set of research bonuses by
taking a picture of the splicer on the other side of the
window.
Keep the subject centered and nearby.
Ah!
Good.
You've got the camera.
Now get me some snaps, snaps on those spider splicers.
And don't come back down here till you've got my research.
Okay.
Wee.
Say cheers.
research level reached spider splicer research bonus
increased damage spider spice spice i can't say this name
spider splicers are vulnerable to anti-personnel rounds
okay i have to take three photos you know that's not gonna
break is it i as soon as i leave this room it's gonna break
i know it
Spider-Cyder.
Jesus loves me.
Yes, I know.
The Bible tells me so.
Oh.
I'm sorry, Father.
I'll do what you said.
I'll do it.
There you are over here.
Come on.
Let's get up with this.
Oh.
Got a guy?
Or did you not count?
You're a different splicer.
Nice shot, thank you.
Okay, I just was double checking that he didn't.
Okay, six.
Oh my gosh, this is so disorienting.
You think you know me?
Oh my god, what happened here?
No!
My garden!
My prize!
My way out.
You think you know me?
So dramatic.
I'm trying to move.
Well, there's a guy down there.
Can I like zoom?
Like, yeah, there was garden.
Can I zoom in?
Can I get a good picture of you?
Whoa!
Leather, lead head splicer.
Multiple subjects.
Is that a rooster?
It absolutely is.
What is this?
Security bullseye.
Are those pesky security cameras getting you down?
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Simply tag your enemies with our photoelectric insects and
those cameras and turrets become your best friend.
That sounds huge.
The background noises are so spooky.
I know, right?
Dramatic pause.
And flip!
I don't know where we are though.
It's kind of spooking me.
Okay, I'm gonna save again, sorry.
It's basically an automatic hack.
Seems like it, but then at the same time, I wonder...
if...
Then, you know, if I don't hack...
I mean, some things are easy to hack, some things are not.
You know what I mean?
So it's like...
But if I hack, I get the Eve and I get the health.
So I guess it's good to have, but also...
Yeah.
Easy peasy.
Oh, so easy.
It's a plasmid though, so you'd be replacing incinerate.
Oh.
We do have enough to get a new plasmid slot.
If I can get there.
And we got some more.
We even got some more atoms.
We're hacking.
Oh, I didn't save actually.
That might have been a mistake.
Uh.
Oh, it's fast.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I'm supposed to go up there.
All right.
Um, yeah.
Nice.
Now you got this.
I got this, baby.
Hack successful.
What do we have anyway?
How did personnel auto rounds?
Was this for my...
Oh, machine gun.
It tells me.
Kind of expensive.
Hacker extraordinary.
Alright,
I hacked two things in a row, I deserve my save.
I feel like I'm literally going at a snail's pace with this
game.
But I do want to try and beat it before I go to Japan.
We shall see.
Oh, oops.
Can you speak up?
I can't hear you over the turret.
Sea slug?
We're blaming the sea slugs' fault?
But it means more Bioshock.
That is true.
That is so true.
for you for discriminating tastes oh this is where I beat
the big daddy okay I can't get through here another big
daddy second big daddy where do I
Where...
Where was that?
Oh, this game gets me all topsy-turvy.
This level has three.
Yes, it did say that.
Oh, I guess I go through here, no?
Okay, just kidding.
I'm like trying not to, you know...
cute myself too.
McDonough.
Uh oh.
Either you build it like a bathtub or she's gonna turn into
a sewer.
Ew.
No, McDonough.
You said we're not gonna build no bathtub.
We're gonna build Eden.
Eden in a bathtub or a sewer.
Do you have the research camera?
Yeah.
Does Big Daddy count as a camera picture?
Does Big Daddy count?
That's a good shot.
Yippee!
All enemies count.
Lucky.
Rosie.
Did that...
Wait, how many more do I need them?
Take photos of splicers to complete your goal.
Also the little sister.
Honestly, I don't even see her.
I know she's there.
Mr. B.
I guess... she's so tiny.
She's so teeny tiny.
Aw, you were gonna come closer to me?
Aw, it would have been gotten a better photo.
No, I'm taking the picture!
Stop!
Okay, hold on.
Right here.
I got her.
Little sister.
Small increases to matter.
Max, Health, and Eve.
Yippee!
Okay, we're going now.
Oh my gosh, there's a lot going on.
There's a lot going on.
Oh!
I just realized I didn't search this guy.
Wow.
And there's more over here.
Awesome.
Okay.
Last save.
Before we keep going.
A lot of rewards.
There's so much to unlock in this game.
Kinda crazy.
There's so much going on.
I'm hacking.
There's a... a long boy?
Long boy!
A little hacking as a tree.
This game is a lot more than shoot the baddies.
I'm discovering that.
Where the heck am I?
Wait, my arrow is gone.
So right now I'm just supposed to be...
Shoot?
I hear a camera.
Okay.
Oh,
my bad.
Oops.
Need three spider splicers.
You're going to be my friend now.
You're going to be my friend.
I promise.
I didn't mean to set you on fire.
It's a rookie mistake, you know.
We all do it.
I'll do it.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Preemptive friendly fire.
My friend.
Thank you, friend!
Oh my god, he summoned the turret!
No, but not for me!
I gotta stop, like, just grabbing and eating stuff.
I gotta stop shoving stuff in my mouth.
This is terrifying.
Oh, crap.
I'm sorry.
Does this not worry anybody else?
Are we not concerned over this?
No?
We're just going to ignore that part?
Okay.
Oh, I need to get pictures of this.
Oh, these guys!
I forgot!
Okay, I gotta get pictures.
Or...
It's fine.
Yeah, it's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Dead ones count?
They do?
Oh, awesome.
That's six.
Smile!
Oh.
It doesn't... Subject is dead.
That's okay.
I get a penalty for it.
Multiple subjects.
Wait, so...
He's posing, too, yeah.
I'm kind of confused how many I'm supposed to get, to be
honest.
I'm, like, kind of, like, confused by it.
I know I just said that, but I'm confused.
It's like that meme calling an ambulance, but not for me.
I hear somebody in here.
Okay.
wait oh where are you you have a limited film yeah I know I
noticed that too so I'm kind of like just don't stop taking
pictures oh oh wait what just happened oh scrounger when
searching containers or corpses you can search again to get
different loot!
Why did I unlock this?
Store engine bank.
Oh my god.
Yikes.
That got me good.
You can buy more later?
Yeah, but how much do I need before I can...
before I can...
Go onwards, you know what I mean?
Jet postal.
The death penalty and rapture.
Councils in an uproar.
Rights in the streets, they said.
But this is the time for leadership.
Action must be taken against the smugglers.
Any contact with the surface exposes rapture to the very
parasites we fled from.
Parasites?
You stretch necks or a small price to pay for our ideals.
Oh, my God.
Or just some stretch necks, yeah.
How tough are you?
I think I can get it.
We'll try.
Ooh.
Oh, oops, not one.
Other way, I need the other way, please.
Ew, yeah.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, yeah.
Ryan is so nice.
Randru.
You'll need a lot, but film is pretty...
cheap for a vending machine so it's all fine.
Okay, then I just will keep taking photos.
Oh, I'm stealing from the register!
That's what I've always... I can hear turrets literally from
every... everywhere.
I can hear turrets from literally everywhere.
Oh, sweet mother sound.
Wait.
I wish I could see.
Like me.
Was lost, but now
I see.
Aw man, I wanted to get a picture.
Hmm, I'll do.
How do, how do, how do, how do, how do.
Security cameras and bots can also be photographed.
Oh my gosh, the motion blur is the worst thing I've ever
seen.
What's...
Spider?
It's you monster.
Oh, it says I've taken two out of three now.
Okay, oh.
Dragging this out and fight me, you bastard.
Oh, subject already photographed.
Oh, come on.
Oh, oops.
Dang it.
I thought I clicked.
I did right click.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, my God.
Sure, sure.
Oh, you can take photo.
I just told me you can take photo of dead enemies.
I got more film.
Um, I don't want to eat the...
I don't want to eat the pep.
I just want to...
Spider splicer organ?
What's that?
More film.
I don't even know how much film I have right now.
Camera time.
I already took a picture of her though.
Oh.
Oh, what's that?
What?
Nice?
Nice!
What?
Oh, that's the drone thing.
Okay.
Wait, do I really need to go over there then?
Probably not, right?
Oh, no, there's stuff.
There is stuff.
Okay, never mind.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Dollars?
I need to buy more stuff at the next vending machine I see.
There's something there too.
Oh wait, there's much, much stuff.
Is she coming in here?
She sounds so close.
Many much.
Yeah, many much things.
Oh.
Ow!
Uh, shoot.
I'm like in a bad spot for real.
Oh my god.
I'm like actually trapped.
Why don't you come in here, lady?
Just shoot the camera.
I mean, I could, yeah.
I didn't realize it was so high up.
Where'd she go anyway?
Oh, dang it!
I could have...
wasted a health kit.
If I had known.
Maybe I did kill her.
I don't see her.
Look at...
More bandages.
Bandages.
What's over here?
Alcohol.
Okay.
Uppies.
Telekinesis can grab it.
Yeah, but I don't have telekinesis equipment.
Right now.
Yeah, see?
Okie dokie.
All right.
Let's go to the other side.
Oh, what?
Oh yeah, I did search it, okay.
Lending machine.
I will buy a first aid kit.
Potato chips.
Oh, film is, okay.
I have seven out of a hundred.
Okay, good kidding.
I have so much money, so I feel like I can buy a couple
things, you know.
If I buy a first aid kit, does that also give me Eif?
12 for 15 film.
Because I hacked it.
Buy more slots, I can't.
Well, that uses Adam instead of...
Instead of...
What is it called?
That uses Adam instead of my many, many.
And I have to go find a specific place.
I haven't even been able to find!
Oh, yeah.
I haven't even been able to find...
I searched these yet.
A thing yet.
I haven't been able to collect my reward.
Where is he?
Oh,
dang it.
Oh, man.
I don't like that I have to switch between.
Oh!
I'm only making it worse for yourself.
Wait, what just happened to him?
Wait!
He just laid down!
He just laid down and died.
What just happened?
He died of cringe.
It was like, there's...
It's no way that's a V-tuber.
We're at Ryan Club!
Wait, where'd he go?
Wait, wait, where'd he...
His body was right here.
This game is so mysterious.
Wait, he disappeared before my very eyes.
Oh, no.
We gotta find the...
Is there one?
I guess, Gatherer's Garden.
Just the one all the way over here.
So, the Circus of Values.
I just saved, didn't I?
We might be in trouble, but, um.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, yes.
Please, please give me what I need.
Please give me what I need.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
All right, that gives us a lot more time.
And, you.
He is napping and teleporting.
Very talented guy.
Save again?
Yeah, you don't have to tell me twice.
Everywhere, everywhere I hear a turret going off.
It's kind of insane.
A circus of aliens.
I see that up there.
I wonder how I can get it.
Is this the guy just killed?
It must be, no?
Let's go find him.
I cannot carry any more machine gun rounds.
Okay, before we go into the spooky tunnel, let's go up here
first.
And maybe regret it?
There's gotta be a...
A turret.
Nope.
No turret?
Oh, there's a guy.
There's a guy coming over.
Where are you?
I'll get a good photo of you.
Does that count?
Aw, man.
Yuck!
Alright.
I love 1, 2, 3.
Minto Savior of the Little Sisters and Slayer of Mr.
Bubbles, what is your undersea wisdom of the day?
Never!
Wait.
N-S-S.
Never stop saving.
Thank you.
I
think you'd still be shooting at me.
We're okay, maybe.
Cigarettes.
Cigarettes give me more Eve.
Drinks give me more health.
I'm closing in on the whole ring.
I pat myself on the back, but let's face it.
These aren't exactly bloodthirsty, desperado that we're
talking about.
Rapture's full of poets, artists, and tennis players.
But this leader there's this...
Fontaine.
He seems to know his way around the grift.
He keeps his nose clean, but not so clean.
But the right people don't know he's not to be trifled with.
Okay, I thought I was going crazy.
I thought that these were just moving sometimes.
And they really are.
I think they're supposed to be swinging, but...
Oh, they're just kind of twitching.
Oh.
I am going to go back and I am going to go...
Let her little sister hold.
I'm going to go under the ground.
I wonder if I can grab this.
Yeah.
Help me get them to safety and I'll be in your debt for
life.
Okay.
The what?
What?
What did I say?
Oh I can I can do this right can I wait who's that in the
background oh my gosh wait there's a couple things in here
can I avoid getting electrocuted me wife and child wrench it
they're gonna hear me though aren't they oh it's so quiet
actually i blew off his hat
my wife and child
can i get this without getting electrocuted all right
Please, please, please, hack, hack, hack.
Oh, it's easy, thank goodness.
What the hell, this is not easy?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh, thanks a lot, game.
Thanks for nothing.
What the heck?
Scary.
Hey, chip, ice cream.
Oh, I watched it.
Yippee!
Some mighty fine wrench.
Come with suppressor equipment!
Alright, hack success!
Oh, I ate.
I was hungry.
Little cream pie.
Oh, this is still around, I'll take those.
Potato chips.
Film!
I swear, I just hear turrets everywhere all the time.
Not all hours.
Am I tinier?
These barrels humongous.
Oh, it seems like I maybe needed to come this way anyway
first.
Cool.
Yes.
Those gun sounds may be a bug, honestly.
Maybe, maybe, right?
Alright, what did you do?
Door control.
Can I hack it?
Oh, I can.
Oh, I did go in a circle.
How many more photos do I need to take?
I'm guessing I have to take three photos of like three
different unique enemies.
Is what I'm guessing I have to do.
I love the dude the flip is so it's so funny
he's like
I'm trying to build a proper financial market and this idiot
keeps going on about this genetic modification that I'll go
spend an hour Just the spider slicers.
Just the spider slicers.
The sickle throwers.
Oh, got it.
I...
did take a picture of the one.
Yes, I did.
Okay, okay.
Enemy!
Are they coming after me?
What?
Wait, why?
I think an enemy tripped.
Oh!
I turned it off for my own.
I'm stupid as hell.
We'll let them handle it.
Whoa.
Camera to take pictures of splicers.
I know, I know.
Oh, what's going on in there?
That's not so good.
Like that.
Hello?
That's like chasing somebody, I think.
I just don't really know what's going on.
Ah, it's so cool!
Oh.
What the heck?
He's outside.
I'm Big Daddy.
Mr. Bubbles.
Hi.
Trying to.
Can't see the walls in the world.
And a proper T-lift, but he's got the Adam.
And that makes him the governor.
Sinking the profits back into bigger and better plasmids,
building them Fontaine Poorhouse.
My camera.
Oh, I missed him.
He was right there.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I'm stuck.
Okay.
He'll come back, right?
Yes!
I knew he would.
It's like trying to get a photo.
at a at like a zoo what do you suppose right right Andrew
Andrew Ryan's tax policy was to build all of this that's a
great what he's right there oh come on I'm stuck again did
rapture have a stock market you're thinking this is too
Sick.
Okay, what was I doing now?
Going in here.
I can see why that guy got got.
But we won't get got.
I'm hanged.
We're fine.
Everything's fine, everything's fine, everything's fine.
Everything's okay!
In Rapture.
There is no, there is no issue of crazy zombie people in
Rapture.
Yeah, it's all daijobu.
Are you coming in here?
You can't, Doug.
I'm on to you.
You'll get over here.
I'm not getting in front of my turret.
You stupid?
You'll come over here.
You come over here?
over.
You come over here.
You think you get over here.
I'm no more naive.
Even though I just hacked this guy.
You think you could get away with this?
I hear his boots.
SpongeBob SquarePants out there.
He's got a gun!
I want
to I'm gonna get the safe, please, mister!
Hey!
Oh.
Hey, buddy.
Come back, come back.
Increase damage!
I got him.
Those ones are spicy.
Ooh, spicy, spicy.
Can I search this?
Oh, potato chips.
Well, actually, I can't lose anymore, so might as well drink
it.
I can't lose anymore, Eve.
I have none.
Ugh, the lighting in here is driving me crazy.
So, let's save, because these ones are harder.
And we hack.
He can neither duck nor goose, so I think he's at a
disadvantage.
Oh jeez, okay, okay, okay.
Ah, shoot.
Uh, shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, uh, uh, no.
I lost already.
Tough.
Don't goose me.
Talk to me, goose.
How do I hack this thing?
You got this, Mito?
Thank you.
If I can get the right stuff that I need...
Oh, here we go.
Ah, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Yes.
Sometimes the game is kind like that, you know, and we'll
give you, like, a little bit of a chain that you need.
I think you played this, I realized I just...
I never realized just how many tip prompts pop up.
Right!
I'm sure there's a way to turn it off, but...
Automatic hack tool.
Wait, what did I get?
You got an auto-hack?
Wait, what else?
What else was in there?
Proximity mine.
Oh, I cannot carry anymore.
Is that a spitter?
Is that the spitty...
Is that the...
Spitty spitter, spitter lady?
Splice and dice and dice and a spinner lady.
The spoooter.
This guy.
Give me all your money, kid.
Take a picture of your ugly mug.
Score too low!
Fine.
Tough crowd.
It has to be her, right?
Because they sing the song.
It's better?
You disappoint me.
To a kickflip.
Have I gone...
this way I don't think so Alright, back to saving New area,
I'm scared Alright, there's so many sad splicers I know,
they're all
Oh my gosh There we go Thus Say it to the Lord That
was so stupid.
Well, you know, fire and water, I didn't quite think about
it, okay?
I just didn't want to get shocked myself.
Turning on all the sinks.
Insert five credits to use the bathroom!
No, I'm jumping over.
You can't make me care.
What?
You know what?
Rapture deserves it.
Fire in the water, bye!
It's a basic need!
Everybody has to use the bathroom!
Okay, I'm kind of curious though.
Oh, oh man.
What is cleaning the toilet?
Mercury?
proximity mine oh I can't carry anymore
cleanest toilet in all of rapture truly look at that that's
pretty spotless all things good
okay oh I thought that was a person there where do all these
people like they just kind of of like...
I thought the
other guy was gonna come out when I got the grenade.
You discovered the main thesis of the game.
I think I had an inkling.
idea that maybe this place was kind of bad just saying maybe
i don't know if it was like the human experimentation or you
know literally everything i don't know what tipped me off
but i had an idea that it might be like kind of kind of not
a great place just an idea just a just a thought
Nah, I think I'm excited.
I would come here on vacation.
Why does the smuggler crate literally never have anything?
You guys are stingy.
It's probably on purpose, though, isn't it?
It's probably to be like, look, the smugglers were good
people.
Oh, oh, he's a splice, splice, splice splitter.
We got the spitters.
Take a research photo of the highest.
I got an action shot!
I got an achievement!
A is the highest grade!
Oh, so that's what it is.
Is the...
Okay, I was wondering what the grade meant.
It's... It is my...
It is the quality of the photo!
Okay, I don't know why I didn't assume that first.
Multiple subjects.
Where's the other one?
Um...
That's scary.
Spitter, splissor, research bonus.
Organs can be used like first aid kits.
Oh, I think, oh god.
Okay, wait, we're getting really...
Wait, now I'm eating organs.
That's like what we're not supposed to do, right?
I'm just a guy.
My plane crashed and now I'm eating organs.
I guess you gotta do what you gotta do to survive.
Cannibalism.
Woohoo!
Sheesh, alright.
Will do!
Who's coming?
Who's here?
Who's coming out?
Yeah, I bet all the smuggler craze are supposed to be empty
on purpose, aren't they?
To be like, look.
It was just people trying to bring in stuff.
That wasn't bad.
It has been zero days since Mint did a cannibalism.
Paid toilets are a great idea.
Think about it.
It will make people really care about their body.
So what they eat.
You don't want a bad burrito making you bankrupt, do you?
Imagine you have to pay for the minute.
Yeah, they're just bringing in Bibles.
They're not bringing in bullets.
Someone just couldn't read.
with a bee!
How was I supposed to know?
You never... Okay though, you say bad burrito but like all
it takes is you could go to the fanciest sushi place ever
and you could still get the runs.
I know it, I know you could.
It can happen to you!
something okay i feel like i'm about to get ambushed for
real though
literally every single smuggler's crate that i've looked at
has had nothing if a spitter splicer splicer splicer how
splice would the spitter splicer make the spider splicer be
it sounds like she's just speaking from experience we have
all had this happen to us with apologies to genesis
digesting england by the pound what what does that mean all
right uh let me let me save again sorry uh just so when i
inevitably reload i am standing right next to the safe and I
don't have to waste any time walking over.
Oh!
No!
I feel like auto-hack is not fun.
I say until I am so frustrated that I must... Oh my god.
Oh, unlucky.
Oh.
Oh!
That was so unlucky.
Yoiks.
Look, our guy is no...
Our guy is no...
Solid snake.
What do you mean?
Man Rapture is the greatest place in the world, and there is
no war in Basingse!
Are we Fontaine?
Oh my gosh.
Yes.
And no, at the same time, please.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
No spoilers being told.
I'm just guesstimating.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's head back, baby.
Here, Frank Phantom.
The turrets are once again doing their jobs.
Who is up there?
Any big daddy out here?
I just want to see him, like, kind of, like, doing, like a
doggy paddle.
Maybe he's so cute.
Maybe he's just, like, through the water.
Now wouldn't that just be the darn, gosh darn cutest thing
you ever done, Shane?
Where do I go?
Oh my gosh, we are like a million light years away from...
Together.
You guys see how brave I've gotten?
I'm starting to hack without even saving first.
Are you proud of me?
Together.
Yeah, together.
A thousand, a million, a zillion, but I'm still saving.
Oh!
I keep not making, trying to make new saves.
Oh, what the heck?
I can hack this too.
A billion dreams of you.
Oh, shoot.
Hmm, nice.
We like, we like when that happens.
I'm coming in.
I'm saving.
I'm saving first before I come in.
Load save.
You wasted a bullet.
Spooky room.
Why is this room so scary?
What's happening in there?
Are you alive?
Corpse.
There's two people here.
Oh my god, Titanic!
Saw a Marsha today.
I'm searching.
Oh, I'm listening.
We saw our Marsha today.
Oh, is this the lady that, her child?
Oh, this is the room.
That is Armaja.
But he was right.
Oh, she told us the code earlier.
She's drawing blood out of a corpse by Fontaine's fisheries.
Her baby.
And then when she was done, she walked off hand in hand with
one of those awful callings.
Oh, this is scary.
Oh.
Shortened alarms.
New engineering.
What sound is more ominous than a yelp?
Yammering security alarm.
With shortened alarms spliced, your personal EM signature
becomes altered to interact uniquely with alarm sensors.
Shortening the period until you'll be free and clear.
Well, we have nothing else equipped there, so why not?
Aw.
That was so sad.
Read that as shortened arms.
I'm turning into a T-Rex!
Um, what's holding the water in?
Wait a second.
Um, there's glass behind that, right?
This room is spooky.
And what's this?
Door control.
You wanna whack it?
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Taking your two dollars.
What were you gonna buy with that anyway?
A candy bar!
Give it a little zap zap.
Where'd he go?
Wait, that was so scary!
There was a head there.
I saw it.
And now it's gone.
There was...
Was that...
Ah!
Shit.
Nothing!
At least give me something if you're gonna sneak up behind
me.
Oh!
Oh, what is going on in here?
Holy!
Oh, I can't pick up anyone.
Hey,
hey!
Hey!
Every time I scoot over, you scoot over!
Did you see that?
That was goofy.
There's a lot of stuff in here.
Okay.
Arresting Fontaine!
Mr. Roy and I believe in Rapture.
But that doesn't mean we always win.
Fontaine Futuristics is the biggest thing going in Rapture.
So let me be plain.
When we arrest that Taurag Fontaine is thieving and
smuggling.
I'm thieving and smuggling.
We won't touch his business interests.
sit on the council because these poor sods trust us not
because god gave us a chair oh arrest yeah arrest arrest
yeah give me your money give me your money all right
you're so funny looking again um we're heading Two!
A...
Goal.
Ah, I haven't... Wait, I haven't been there yet.
Psew!
Is that one there?
Wait, is that a drone?
People drone?
Why?
Wait, why is there a drone?
Um...
Can drones just happen?
What's this?
I don't think it's friendly, is it?
I can't tell.
It's looking right at me.
I don't know!
He was looking right at me!
It's being controlled by a splicer.
Oh, is that what's happening?
Oh my god, are you kidding me right now?
Oh my god.
I hold you!
Shoot.
He's not going to come after me, right?
I promise I'm good.
What HP?
I think there is a...
Yeah, there is.
Aww, they're so cute.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to say real quick, I don't know.
I'm nervous because I don't know yet how close I can get.
Actually, you know what?
Let's test it right now.
I'll test it.
Save always.
Honestly, it's good to anyway.
What do you mean to say?
I'm pretty close.
He's like, shoot.
Shoot.
Okay, wow, you can actually get really close, can't you?
It's getting close to the little system.
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna corner myself at some point.
Ouch.
Uh, shoot.
Oh, my god.
We got him!
No, no, come back!
The turret noises in the background are killing me.
me where'd
she go you're welcome where are you hello oh there she goes
I pushed them off the holy cow time for nap sweet angel
she's so cute bye I love the way they clip through the hole.
Poor guy.
What do you mean?
Why?
Minky no.
I saved her.
All right.
Where are we going?
This way.
I want that up there.
Oh, if I had...
Wait!
We can swap our telekinesis, right?
And we can get it.
Security ball.
Oh, that's right.
Ah, that's right.
I mean,
if I have this, then I don't need the electricity,
technically.
Learning the gene bank.
Yay!
You started that fight with that grenade launcher, and as it
exploded, I can't knock something big over to scare the
butchings is out of me.
If I...
I think this is temporary though.
I think so.
Well, anyway.
For now, we'll switch this out.
I forgot how to use the telekinesis.
Wait.
Oh!
Well, I still got it.
It works.
I want to try.
I'll try using the telekinesis for a bit.
Um...
I'll try.
Re-learning it.
Right now, do I want to buy anything?
I'm deciding.
How much film?
11.
You know what?
Yeah, let's just buy a first aid kit because why not...
Welcome to the circus of value!
Use it like a grav gun.
Yeah!
One more little sister to get in this level?
I thought...
Where was it?
It was like towards the beginning.
Um, she was...
The one that I didn't get that was by the fishery, I'm
pretty sure.
You have so much money.
I know!
Fine, I'll get him on one.
I'm a hoarder.
You guys know this by now.
The circus.
Oh, well, you...
I'm supposed to go with that.
Oh.
Oh boy.
Multiple subjects.
Oh,
out of him!
Out of!
You are not friend, you are not friend, you are not friend,
you are not friend, you are not...
When did they set this up?
Who set this up?
When did this, when did this happen?
Oh!
I don't think I got it, though.
Oh, I did.
Hack, hack, hack, hack!
It happened when it happened.
Oh, I'm hacking.
Oh, dang it, it was an easy one.
I'm going to accidentally click that auto hack, I swear.
And I'll be really sad about it when I do.
Especially if it's on an easy one.
Or one that I want to do.
There we go.
I love hacking
Oh the fishes scared me Not the pet bar Oh they took out the
camera Oh I did eat the pet bar I'm so stupid They took out
my camera It was here I remember
Okay yeah it was Oops Oh no
you didn't No, you just thought that a city under the sea
would be safe.
And that if anyone went mad with power, that they would
totally let you out and go home.
Wife guy.
Minto merch idea, you could sell pipes.
What the hell?
Upper wharf.
Oh my god, why are we screaming?
Hello?
Oh, this was not open before.
My god.
Wait.
Where is that?
Where are you?
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Big daddy.
I gotta be careful.
Don't hit big daddy.
Oh, he's got...
She does have little sister with him, though.
An anxiety smoker, but instead of smoking, you save.
Yeah, that sounds about right.
That sounds accurate.
How many do I have?
Proximity mine?
Only one fragment is.
and five proximity mines get a pick I've gotten a pick of
these two before though I mean I guess I can take another
yeah see subject already photographed it gives you like
nothing I don't think it's worth it wasting your
what is this guy shooting?
No.
Who is shooting?
I don't think it's worth wasting film just to get like a
teeny tiny bit.
I need to go that way though.
No!
Oh.
I was trying to grab this.
No!
Okay, I give up.
He walked by his dead body.
Shoot it to Oh, I guess we could do that too, right?
No.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Please come back, though, so I can actually...
Yes, thank you.
We did get two little sisters, so I'm honestly okay for
right now.
Wait, this guy doesn't even have one.
Oh, never mind.
It would have been a...
Well, not a waste, but you know what I mean.
But the other guy did...
Wait, so that means...
There's another one.
Oh gosh.
Okay, ah.
She left, he put her to bed!
Oh, she went in the hole!
Um, hold on.
Yeah, let's do this.
And do this.
And I'm going down this way.
I'm kind of lost, I don't remember exactly where.
everything is.
Oh, I remember.
I could crawl under here.
Anything new?
Okay.
Oh, yes, I remember.
I remember.
My turrets have been doing such a great job, it seems.
Female splice.
Oh, I just noticed this thing.
Oh my gosh.
Wrench lure When fighting, though, stronger or faster than
yourself, you'll need every advantage possible in a Scrum.
Wrench Lurker allows you to make the most of your
opportunities when your antagonist is caught off guard.
Oh.
Wait, so it's just like a sneak attack?
I have wrench.
Oh, quiet your footsteps and increases damage from melee
attacks on unaware opponents.
Oh, wow, this, okay.
I have this where you yeah this one is if they damage you
you emit static and this one makes my wrench stronger so
honestly I feel like I could oh no it's stealth
oh let's try it
Oh my god Oh
hi I don't even know notice you wait
did I get hurt from that or
oucha where
is she she's so hard to see
everything is happening all at once oh my god lady can you
die already where
is she
I'm just gonna...
Oh my god!
Ouch!
She's so beefy.
Where are you?
Oh my god, please!
Please!
Oh my god!
Oh my stinking god!
I don't know who you are!
Just die already!
Why is she?
What the bear, please?
Where is she going?
Oh my god.
Because I'm afraid of commitment!
Oh, damn it.
I didn't think that went through.
Is that doing damage to her?
I can't tell, to be honest.
Oh my god.
I'm actually going crazy.
Why is she not dying?
It does?
Okay.
Where is she?
Where did she go?
You can't do all that to me and then leave.
Ma'am?
My crates.
You have found your first reward from Tendenbaum for saving
little sister.
New Plasmid, hypnotized Big Daddy.
Need a bodyguard in a pinch?
Our new hypnotized Plasmid will fool a Big Daddy into
protecting you as if you were its own little sister!
Minta little sister.
She already ran to a heal station.
Wait, so I'm not... I wasn't going crazy.
It looked like her health went up.
No stinking way.
I'm little sister.
Minto, imoto.
But for now, we store in the gene bank because there's no
guy here.
Oh.
I also got something else, but I don't know what.
Hold on.
Is she back?
Please say no.
Dear God, please leave me alone.
Okay, let's just ignore her for a second we're just gonna
i'm gonna buy another plasmid slot we're gonna ignore her
for like two seconds okay anyway um i
already know about that one though okay um
speedy hacker i could get another plasmid slot we have quite
a bit now I could fit in there.
Fire spreads.
More slots.
Armored shell?
I think, I think, honestly, armored shell is pretty good
to...
Oh, shoot!
Wait, how can I open up more slots here?
Oh, dang it.
I don't even think about it.
Okay, I can't tell if this does much, the static discharge.
You'll have to buy more later.
Barry Raiders!
Thanks, Barry!
Wait, I didn't see it.
I'm so sorry.
I think I was getting my butt wiped by that lady.
Oh my gosh.
You can tell how Minto's done with your boss fight stick as
soon as she pumps the shotgun.
We got raided!
I was trying.
I was fighting for my afterlife.
Oh, thank you, Barry.
Um.
Maybe this would be better, though.
I don't know.
Okay, another plasmid slot.
And then I'll save up for more later.
Eva, wait, how long will Big Daddy love me?
Do you have all the plasmids that let you shoot out bees?
I don't have a plasmid that lets me shoot bees.
That's a deep question.
How long will he love me?
Last a good while?
Maybe till death.
Till death do us part.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Lady.
Leave me alone!
You are so annoying!
You are actually so annoying!
Please!
Oh my god, that's all it took.
Oh yeah, she went down real easy, thank you.
Snap-y, snap-ys.
Okay, hold on.
I don't want this one right now.
hypnotized big daddy wait I'm just imagining all the tiny
crawl spaces I go through what is he gonna do what will
where will he go he's too big daddy what is the angry clock
oh reduces the duration that's right ew what oh my arm guys
we don't look so good wait we don't look so good are we okay
this one is sick that one's sick okay
nah it's fine okay I believe you hey who's this this nice
I think it's somebody below us wow I wasted so much on that
lady.
I had bought so many first aid kits and everything.
And she wasted them.
Wasted them.
We're good for that though now.
Oh wait, I'm stuck.
No, my turret's even gone.
Shoot at me.
Oyster All right For those guys use that Wait No wait Which
gun was the anti-personal Oh no This one Okay okay That's
right They did say that Oh You have not rescued or harvested
All the little sisters on this deck You need for them to
become more powerful it will be very difficult to survive
without getting more Adam
are you trying to tell me something or imagine shaking that
hand mini boss is probably just hangry true yeah that is a
scary warning isn't it oh that's a scary warning okay okay
okay I think I just saved in an eye yeah we We just have the
one more to get.
That might be a warning.
It's like, girl, you do not have enough.
I know it for sure.
There's something.
Oh, that's not sparkling.
It's just...
Um...
Well, question.
Can I hypnotize a big daddy and then...
the girl?
Go get Adam, the game subtly hinted.
No.
Oh, that's lame.
She leaves!
What if I grab her real fast?
I can't tell where this is at.
This room looks like... I haven't been able to go in there,
I think.
At least not that I remember.
I like my pistol too much.
My revolver.
Oh, I hear him?
Maybe?
I don't know where I hear him.
Well, he was up here before, wasn't he?
Oh yeah, he's in there.
All right, hold on, let me save.
Oh, game!
Game!
Oh, they are on the map!
Are they?
Where am I?
No, they're not.
They're not on the map.
Oh, I should have got him.
One guide.
I truly was.
Wait.
Okay, that's right.
I can't hypnotize them.
Um, this is like such a bad...
Wait, I wish I could...
E!
No!
I need, I need her!
Now!
Oh, this is, like, the worst area!
I want to try it, though.
You're mine, now.
She's like, hello?
She's so confused.
She doesn't know what to do!
Come back here.
Oh, this is so lame.
I guess it would be pretty OP though, wouldn't it?
It'd be pretty OP.
Now, if I attack him...
Does he...
Where is she going?
Um...
He immediately aggro's on me.
Okay, wait a second then.
We do need her around, though.
Where did she go?
Hello, little girl.
Little girl, I'm not...
Wait, was I...
Oh, there she is.
She's just wandering around.
I don't know what to do.
Wait, is that...
No way.
Someone just dropped this.
Oh my god.
I hate the way you shake the camera.
Can we not do that?
Oh, thank you.
Thanks.
Oh my god, please.
You're gonna give me...
I'm gonna get motion sickness from you.
Oh, I think he's back to normal.
Oh, but she's leaving.
Oh my god, the worst timing ever.
Wait, so he doesn't stay...
Okay, well now we know he doesn't stick around forever.
No, that is awkward, isn't it?
...
Um...
Well now we know.
Science experiment complete.
Yeah, it was pretty long though, it was.
But we lost her.
Yeah, I'm gonna reload, you're right.
Oh, let's see, alright.
Yeah, it's like two minutes.
That's good.
Good to know.
Hmm.
Okay.
Now...
Oh, come on.
Get Mr. Bubbles!
I'm not your...
Well, I am your enemy, but...
Alright.
Alright, hold on.
Now let me do a new save.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I have four of these.
One of these.
Oh, okay.
He's back there.
He's back there, perfect.
Oh my god, there's two of them!
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait.
There's only supposed to be three little...
Wait, there's only supposed to be three little sisters, and
I already got two of them.
Can you get them to fight each other?
Can they?
Hypnotized.
Oh, you're so right.
Oh, wait, wait.
And then aggro on this guy, right?
Uh.
I'm trying not to shoot the other guy, though.
It's like a kaiju battle.
Yeah!
She looks so scared, it's so sad.
Are they even doing anything?
Oh, nice!
They finally hit it!
Yay!
Rescue.
Please, rescue.
Oh!
Nice!
Oh my god, that was so awesome!
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thanks for the money.
And you are, um...
Well...
I don't know what to do with you now.
You're free to go?
The dads are fighting?
That was so awesome.
finish him off but i won't get oh wait i think he's god oh
yeah he's he's god
rosy what happened to our other big daddy i like the other
design more i think we lost uh we lost um oh there it is
We lost the little sister, though.
I'm so confused, though.
Where does it show how many little sisters are on the map or
on the level?
Because I'm curious what it will say now.
They swap every level-ish.
Ah, okay.
Bouncer is the iconic Big Daddy.
Yeah.
Oh, it's Pausmania.
That's so funny.
I guess maybe it did glitch out when I...
loaded?
Somehow?
He doesn't know what to do.
Are you lost?
Oh, wait.
I'm just gonna follow him down.
And try...
Hope that a little sister does not crawl out of the hole so
that I don't get to Oh, I don't aggro him on an accident.
I saved so much ammo.
I really... It was awesome!
right okay gotta go this i do have to go this way right yeah
yeah
following the dairy
yeah they do move
making my camera all wobbly though it does give me a little
motion sick i don't think it will give me motion sick if my
screen wasn't full screen you know I mean he's half health
but I don't feel like we should take him just because we
don't have he doesn't have a little sister right okay bye
okay the game can't get mad at me now okay the game can't
get mad at me now they do drop loose That's true.
That is true.
They do drop loot.
I'm knocking.
The war rat didn't get himself that.
Nope.
You got something from me and my crew?
Or are you just looking to get criticized?
You set here a spell.
A spell.
I need to set on some coffee.
Maybe puts on silverware in the light.
I need to talk like Smeagle.
Put on silver wares.
Precious.
Before you head into the fisheries, award to the wise.
All peachy seems about as straight as the dog's heart.
Okay.
Oh.
Nobody walks into my swampy carry ain't a heat.
Put your weapons in the no more.
And then I'll let you in.
The no more.
Relinquish your weapons.
That's true.
Oh boy.
Focused hacker.
Wait, what is it?
I own it.
Let me grab it.
Do I already have this one?
Is that why it won't let me have it?
Oh, the game is like, hey buddy, you should really...
Oh, fire the mill.
Oh, I forgot about that.
that thank you guys um
dude oh there was even stuff in there too another favorite
in the hack smart line of gene tonics focused hacker
diffuses overload traps and secure systems fewer fried
circuits guaranteed for your money back well equip it
because i don't have anything else wait do you think there's
something in here too though
Nothing.
Search.
I'm searching.
That's a whole lot of bullets.
Just water.
now we shall relinquish.
Nothing.
Send weapons!
Ah!
You now have no weapons except your wrench.
Automatic hack tool.
I should have not taken that.
I don't need it.
I didn't need it anyway.
Can I incinerate boxes?
Now, I bet when the boss waggled out of hell, no.
I'm told the devil he'd be right back and the devil says,
sure, thank you.
mr fontaine i'll hold you a spot ryan promised fontaine was
dust and now here you are doing his dirty i guess that makes
ryan a bum and you would me a what
Oh, I healed too preemptively.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh, they're all over.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
Where are other people at?
I'm trying to run away.
Oh, this part's scary.
They're just on fire.
Alarm activated!
I'm trying!
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
Okay, maybe the fire is not the run.
Okay, that's fine.
That's okay.
I mean, it could be the run.
I'm gonna reload because I lost all my health kits, you
know.
You gotta shoot, too.
With what gun?
What do you mean?
You gotta shoot or I don't have a gun.
Oh my god, this is real.
really uh oh hold on sorry my head this is really testing if
uh you know your your uh what's it called though i gotta
block this guy i'm not even gonna do the hack tool your um
powers plasmids yes my plasmids Alrighty, alrighty, um, I
can telekinesis his bombs.
I'll try and remember that.
I can zap him, and I can set him on fire.
I wish my hand could easily go up to F1.
And that flurry from Washta.
It's a little tricky, I feel.
What triggered the alarm?
I don't know!
That, okay, now I know there's an alarm to it.
trip over there i suppose so i guess i shouldn't i should
try to avoid that area also can i telekinesis these barrels
f no f3 f2 f3 f2 f3 don't forget your one two punch yeah my
my handy dandy wrench this is really testing if you know
your what's it called binto i don't think you're prepared
There's a camera in the L-shaped wall you hid in.
Ah, I see, I see.
You could hack them while he talks.
The cameras?
Could we?
Okay.
Is that that red light that I'm seeing?
All right, I'm sorry.
I'm going to say it one more time.
I don't remember what...
This one's a tricky fight, but you got this.
Good luck, boss.
Thank you.
It is tricky because there's so many...
going on!
F2.
Oh, wait.
Not this.
F1.
Ha.
La la la.
La la la la la la la.
Wrong one.
La la la la la.
I need one more long boy.
Long boy?
Long boy.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
This game is probably easier with controller.
Wait, I can't tell if you're serious.
I
don't know where I am.
Actually.
Okay, I am gonna save here, though.
I don't know if this is a good time to save, but just
because I hacked it.
Promise Fontaine was dust, and now here you are doing his
dirty...
I guess that makes Ryan a bomb, and you...
Me?
Hello?
Where is he, anyway?
Oh my god.
Well, it would really help to...
Ah!
I don't like this.
I think I'm doing a bad job, guys.
I can't even pick that up.
I can pick this one up, though.
Does this block?
Ah!
I think I'm doing a poor job here.
Oh, oops.
I did it?
No.
Holy shit.
Oh, thanks Atlas, thank you.
I don't know, actually.
Wait, I'm confused.
Wait, I did it, but I didn't.
I did it, but I didn't.
The turret killed him?
Wait.
I'm actually so confused.
I've got a run pass.
I'll take that.
Thank you very much.
Wait, no way.
Oh my gosh.
You son of a gun.
Because you are a gun.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Um, oh, spooky number!
I'm gonna try and get it.
You killed him with the barrel.
I'm so confused.
I'm not mad about it.
I'm just really confused.
I thought I was doing so poorly.
I mean, I was.
I feel like I was doing so bad.
Okay.
Sure!
Why don't we take those?
I don't know.
Alright, whatever.
You were doing mediocre.
I'm honestly so confused.
Okay, it's like right there.
Shoot.
Oh, I did get it.
I did get it.
Oh, but it's so far away.
No.
Can I?
Oh, I might need to blow it up.
Hmm.
I only have one.
I could go buy some more health packs.
Oh, I have nothing to blow it up.
I forgot.
That's right.
I was like, wait, where are my weapons?
Burn it with fire!
I don't know if it's working or not.
I think you can go back and get your stuff.
Oh, you think I can?
Are you dead yet?
Electricity?
Electricity!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Values.
Wait, what's my health like, oh yeah, let's purchase a
potato jeeps.
chomp chomp chomp chomp chomp oh they give you like nothing
do they oh they're cheap
circus oh i got a pistol
he's so funny iconic let me see if i can get my stuff back
circus oh value i can't sad okay i can kill him with two
shots that moves.
So, do I, um...
LVs or...
Oh, some poor sap was laying there.
Oh
my god, are you serious right now?
Ah!
I didn't need to take a photo of her on fire.
Mad on fire!
Imagine setting up shop.
Girls throwing barrels.
Yeah, how is this not an A?
It's an action shot.
Oh, shoot.
Oh,
so these are like opening up doors.
Okay, very cool.
I ate a kick.
I took her.
Oh, geez.
This is annoying.
Oh, my God.
This wouldn't be nearly as annoying if I didn't have this
stupid thing that I can't do anything about, you know?
It's actually so frustrating.
Wait.
Can I barrel it?
Ah!
Bad idea!
Oh, gosh.
It's so annoying.
It's actually so annoying.
Oh, that's a body.
We have nothing on you, though.
Zap it is temporary, you guys.
Maybe if I zap it again and...
And set it on fire again?
I don't know what to do.
Ha!
It's so fast, too.
How...
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh my god.
Oh, so annoying.
Anyway, just go down the stairs.
There's stairs?
Oh,
my stuff.
My stuff.
Can I get him now, though?
I don't know if I can.
Uh, search.
Pet boar.
I'm exploring a little bit.
I lost my med kits.
I noticed that I had fewer.
Wait, where'd they go?
Okay.
Oh yeah, you're really making me want to open it up.
Power to the people.
Fontaine Futuristics.
Upgrade weapon.
Wait, what's this mean?
Wait, hold on, sorry.
I'm just going to save again because I don't...
I hate dealing with that stupid turret.
Oh!
The auto-generated sharp-shaped charges make you immune to
the damage from your old grenades!
Oh!
This machine will be disabled.
You get one upgrade.
I feel like damage immunity is pretty big.
Kickback reduction is also pretty good.
Pistol clip size.
No.
Six shots.
More than enough to kill anything.
That moves.
But Damage up.
Damage up is pretty cool too.
Rate of fire.
Yeah, six shots is more than enough.
Ew.
I feel like, honestly, damage immunity is like the biggest.
Because knowing me, a big daddy would be standing right next
to me.
And I would pull out my grenade launcher.
And I'd be like, eat this!
We both die.
But I do use my shotgun a lot.
Gas-assisted firing mechanism increases.
For you, it's pretty good.
What's that supposed to mean, huh?
What's that supposed to mean?
You're a shotgun baddie.
You can eat shrapnel for breakfast.
Eat this and you share a meal.
I've just taken my fork and...
Right in there, meal.
Shotgun's always a win.
Yeah, but which one should I do?
The damage increase or the rate of fire?
Damage?
Okay.
Look at her.
She's beautiful.
You can't take it from me, Ryan.
Give me one second.
I think I'm going to go get some more water.
Actually, no.
What is my goal?
Show hint.
The passage in the hidden...
Oh.
So I am supposed to be opening these up.
I didn't want to tell me where it was, though.
Just give me...
A hint is not supposed to...
A hint is not supposed to be like, By the way, it's in the
basement!
Go get some water, Minky.
I will.
I am... I will.
I did just save, right?
Okay.
I don't think it's this one.
I think it's this one.
And if it's not, we're testing our shotgun.
I wanna...
Woo!
Ouch, Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
Hey!
Why was that so hard for me?
Holy cow.
Three shots.
I don't think you can get away with this?
I completely forgot that like this exists.
Right.
Ouch!
Yikes.
I was just yapping in here.
Wait, is this...
Oh, no.
I was picked the wrong one.
I did pick the wrong one.
Well, honestly, we can probably just listen to all or go
into all of them.
He's squeezing us out of 80 points of our cut with the
threat of turning us into Ryan.
don't play ball son of a bitch sammy g comes and tells me
he's thinking of going to the constable and the next day
sammy sammy g is found in a sack in a salt pond we had no
choice here we stay on fontaine's crew and we're gonna catch
the gallows we take a powder and we end up like sammy g not
sammy g everybody calls him sammy g for sammy gone oh no
Why do they full name him like that?
Oh my gosh, please.
Okay.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Yes.
There we go.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, bam.
Happy 11 months, me, Tom, almost a one-year sick, my top.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
We're 11 months.
What did we get?
We'll take all of that.
Thank you.
Okay, well, I guess maybe it's this one.
Ghost.
What kind of operation is Fontaine running here?
Oh, okay.
Erm.
Oh, wrong thing.
Oh, my god, I wasted it.
Wasted it for that.
Music.
Oh, hello.
Can I get there, please?
Wait.
Hello?
Do I need to melt more?
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Wait, guys, I'm stuck.
Okay, I'm not stuck anymore.
I don't believe that for one second.
Smooth sailing in my horror game.
Impossible.
Yay!
Smugglers hideout!
Wait, did we actually make it?
Wait, is that actually smooth sailing?
The smuggler has been smuggling potato chips.
Those dang guys.
And peppy bars.
Ah!
Sorry.
What the hell is that?
I got flashbanged by old people.
Then she just cutscene.
Well then why don't you get them?
If they're a hundred yards away.
I hear a vending machine.
Why are the smugglers living in water?
Oh wait, everybody's living in water.
water.
My bad.
Oh!
The Siggies.
I shouldn't probably waste uh health right now though.
Don't we have a vending machine actually though?
Does this count as like... Ooh!
Underwear.
Wait, what was that?
Oh.
compromised?
I think so.
Well, actually, I think they just don't like me.
Does that answer your question?
I was going to ask though, does this count as like a new
area, like a new chapter?
Because we went through the wharf and everything.
I don't, I guess this game doesn't super have like, yeah, we
were at Neptune's bounty and now we're in a smuggler's
hideout.
So I think I might call it here then.
And we can continue.
This is a short one.
Oh, is it?
How short are we talking?
I guess I don't...
It's an in-between chapter.
Oh, it's really short?
Okay, we can do it then.
We can do it then.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run, run, hackin.
Hacking, hacking, hacking.
Hacking to the game.
Vodka.
No, no.
Pistol?
Shotgun?
Eve?
Wow, they love chips!
They're just, wow, they love chips!
They're just like me, for real, for real!
I love a potato chip!
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh, I didn't mean to drink that.
That's fine though.
Peppy bar.
Mmm.
Oh.
Meeting with Fontaine.
We all come down here.
Figured we all be part of Ryan's great chain.
Turns out Ryan's chain is made of gold.
And ours are the sort with the big iron ball around your
ankle.
Yeah.
He's up in Fort Frolic banging fashion.
We're down in this dump yanking guts out of fish.
Fontaine's promising something better.
He's like one of us, you know.
Like he's worked a day in his life.
He says meet him at his fish packing joint at 11.
guys hey it's not like things could get a lot worse how
could things get worse
hmm sauna actually where do I go do I go oh I came from over
there just I'm just kidding, I get it.
Dang, I was making off good.
Oh no, he dropped his whiskey even.
Dang, the guy was taking the whole bar with him.
Oh, find the submarine.
Is he gonna get mad at me?
Is he gonna be like, I know who you are?
If you press that button, you'll learn what it means to
truly be my enemy.
Randrew!
I think I already know.
I don't know.
Kind of annoying.
Too bad I don't need these.
Like, I...
I wish they were first aid kits.
I don't know how to balance.
I don't know.
Wait, which way?
Are we supposed to go this way or this way?
Through the hole?
I need gamer paint?
Please?
Oh, there we go.
Ran true.
I can't call him anything else.
Oh, wait.
Yeah!
Games like, where are you going?
You stupid ghost.
This looks like a loop- this looks like a boss area.
I'm not gonna lie.
This looks like a boss area.
boss area oh all
my stuff got mixed around now because because my look at all
that cash oh yeah someone was a little butterfingers over
here Frank Fontaine crowd scientist she's damaged goods all
right all right just like all those chumps they scraped out
of them prison camps oh but she's no crackpot she's gonna
make me the kind of scratch that'll have Ryan look like he's
running a paper route she just needs some supplies to get
the ball rolling and a Friend to watch her back.
Friend to watch her back.
I'm an old gangster type.
Yeah, I'm the old gangster type.
Wait, hold on.
Just because I don't know if I'm doing the order of
operations wrong.
I saw the lever up there, but I want to go look at this
first.
Oh, wait.
What do we tell him?
It ain't looking so good, Alice.
You know what movie I watched recently That I hadn't watched
in a really long time Was A Train to Busan Did you guys ever
watch that?
I feel like Correct me if I'm wrong Maybe there was another
movie But I feel like it was one of the very first Like
Korean movies that hit International fame There was a sequel
Was there really?
This Korean zombie flick right?
Yeah, yeah, I watched it again recently.
That and Parasite.
I think Parasite, for sure.
But I feel like a lot of people talked about Train to Busan,
right?
Old boy.
Oh, Old boy kind of did, but it was more niche.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Old boy, probably.
Yeah, that's true.
Ah, forgot about Old boy.
Yeah, you're right.
But I think because, like, when Train to Busan, came out, it
was on Netflix.
And it was like so, it was like when, you know, streaming
Korean movies became more accessible.
Hmm.
So, yeah.
To train, to busa.
But, oh man, I watched it recently and I was like, oh my
gosh.
It's so, it's, you know, it's one of those like, like kind
of almost like a doomer zombie movie.
So if you haven't watched it before, I don't know if you
don't like those kinds of like, oh God, that favorite
character?
Yeah, they're dead, you know.
Like I wouldn't recommend it then if you don't like those
kinds of things.
But, um, and then I found out recently about another movie.
Sorry, I don't know why that guy talking about his family
reminded me of, of, because like Train to, oh, Train to
Busan is all like about, um, the guy's family and stuff and
I will save just because um but I've learned about another
movie recently that I I don't want to watch it but it's
called Passengers it's with Chris Pratt but basically okay
but what is so fascinating about this movie it is it is a it
is a love story but the movie is a horror movie like truly
but they but they that movie is messed up it's really messed
up so i'm gonna spoil it a little bit if you guys don't mind
um it's kind of so messed up so basically like i said i
didn't watch it i kind of watched like a like a a video
essay on it kind recently about like if you re-edited the
movie it would change the entire tone of it um but so it's
about a spaceship that's going someplace i think to like
another colony and it has like it's going to be there in
like 200 years or something um and like earth earth 200
years or something something of like some you know egregious
amount of time right that nobody would survive if they
And Chris Pratt's little sleep pod wakes him up early.
Wakes him up like 90 years early or something.
So he's like, he's like, oh, shoot.
What do I do?
And this guy.
This guy wakes up another lady.
It doesn't tell her.
And he's like, oh, no.
Earpod also.
woke you up.
And then eventually she finds out.
Yeah, Jennifer Lawrence.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And eventually she finds out and she's like, what the hell,
dude?
And he's like, my man.
And then she's like, no, I still love you.
He literally dooms her to die on the ship with him.
And...
I just...
And it was kind of interesting.
The...
The video that I watched about it was basically like...
So, you know, the movie shows Chris Pratt waking up and him
kind of going about his day and then being like, Me so
lonely!
And wakes her up and then this and that and the other, you
know?
But...
The video describes like if he Instead of Edited the movie
Where Where when the girl Wakes up Right And she's And then
She also sees Chris Pratt She's like When Jennifer Lawrence
Wakes up She sees Chris Pratt And she's like Why are you
awake Because nobody else Is awake And he's like I don't
know And then they go around And they see like Kind of
remnants Of things that Like he had done Throughout the time
That he Like they I think he like Waits a year Or something
Before he Wakes her up And Yeah it does have Lawrence
Fishburne in it too it does yeah um and uh like there's
something that happens and Chris Pratt goes to sacrifice
himself and then she saves him and she's like no I do love
you but it kind of then turns into like a mystery rather
than like a like a mystery kind of creepy like and you see
how creepy he's acting and everything don't want to watch
the movie but i was like so fascinated by it just like how
how it you know stuff like that where you can like re-edit a
movie changes the entire tone tonal shift of it i don't know
i'm just so fascinated anyway sorry for my tangent she was
mad for like a little while about how he basically tried to
murder her he did it's so bad anyway we're hacking this it's
so oh my gosh like I want to watch it but I don't at the
same time because I'm like obviously now I know how the
movie ends because I spoiled myself I can't I had nobody to
blame but myself for that but at the same time oh wait
I wish they had done the other edit okay it's
mid-forgettable movie, I forgot it existed.
I think had they done the other editing, like the one that
I, where you start where she wakes up instead, I think it
would have been a little more like exciting and kind of
like, oh, we have to, we see like that, it looks like
somebody has lived here for a while, but we only just woke
up, what's going on, you know?
Not a movie, but for a good Korean zombie TV series, I
definitely recommend All of Us Are Dead.
It's on Netflix too, if you want stuff it's fine oh thank
you garland mode i'll check it out thanks for the pink thank
you thank you thank you so much thank you thank you
compelling at least yeah okay anyway let's go let out this
guy's family if they're really in there at all what's
he doing
oh no
She was wearing the cool mask that I was used to.
Fire spreads, everybody.
Ouch.
They don't come from behind, do they?
I don't think so.
Oh.
I think they...
I don't have, like, a time limit or anything.
Get out if you can't!
Get out!
Wait, why am I getting out now?
Oh!
Her mask!
That was crazy!
I got her good.
Oh!
No!
You lose in like an assassin, and then you try to sneak out
like a thief.
But no CIA spook.
Who are you?
I don't know.
There's two ways to deal with the mystery.
Uncover it or eliminate it.
Thank you.
Oh, it's family!
Get out!
Get out and get to Arcadia!
Ripperoni.
Poor guy.
He's just been helping us.
Well, you know, tempting.
Oh, did I...
I'm trying to get everything.
Sorry, I'm looting bodies while you mourn your family.
Don't mind me.
Wait, that other spitter lady disappeared.
Wait, I don't think I got all the bodies up here.
Rip and pepperoni!
They died.
With lots of money in their pockets.
Aww.
So sad.
Yeah, the cremation is taken care of.
Lutover family.
Star Wars episode 3 and black and white dubbed in Japanese
with no subtitles.
I bet it changes the entire feel.
I believe you.
Oh.
Offered a deal.
The Irish pork pie offered me a deal.
I flip Infantine and I walk out of here.
That's simple.
How do I know that fat fuck isn't Fontaine's guy?
They're not all Fontaine's guy.
Fontaine's got Adam, and everybody wants it.
Brian's got a whole lot of talk and a nice suit.
Even down here, any idiot can see which way the wind is
blowing.
To Arcadia.
It's going to be a gross hour movie.
All right.
Ooh, Arcadia looks pretty.
Cool, then we will pick this back up on a Saturday when I
next play.
Oh, Patrick.
Yeah, get angry.
I came to this place to build the impossible.
Andrew is on the phone too.
Oh my god, how awkward.
He was eavesdropping.
Even the air you breathe is sponged from my account.
Well, breathe deep.
So later you might remember the taste.
Oh!
You get to the bathysphere in the rolling hills.
That'll take you straight to the devil himself.
All right.
And then all debts will be paid in full.
Oh yeah, I'm going to give him the one two.
New goal.
Go to the metro station.
All right, we will head to the metro station next time.
Thank you guys so much for Bioshock today.
I don't, honestly, I have no idea how far we are in the
game.
Thanks for this dream, Vicky.
Hope your head feels better.
Drink lots of water.
Thank you.
Also, uh, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Um, pencil tip.
Thank you for the super chat, too.
YouTuber pop culture detective did a whole video on the
abduction as romance trope because of the past.
No way!
Wait, I kind of want to watch it now.
This game's so hectic and loud.
Was it too loud?
I'm so sorry.
If the sound was too loud.
The passenger's edit would have been way better.
Wishing you a nice, calm, comfy, quiet, rest of your night.
Thank you, Dwargo.
Thank you.
It wasn't.
It was fine.
It wasn't for us.
Okay, good, good, good.
Arcadia is the best level.
Can't wait for the next stream.
Me too, though.
Me too.
Thought it would sound good?
Okay.
I'm glad.
the style of the game true very very true it is the style of
the game yeah it's it is it is noisy for sure it is lots of
noise volume was good just meant noisy in general yeah thank
you yeah chaotic many many many many i'm so sweaty holy cow
i i just showered i just showered and i'm tripping ectoplasm
again I gotta shower again.
This game makes me stressed.
But tomorrow is Creature Kitchen, and that game is very
chill and cute.
Thank you for the fun stream.
Thank you, Melody.
Thank you, thank you.
And yes, of course, I will be in NIMMY's 3D live.
So after Creature Kitchen, we will raid into NIMMY's live.
And yeah.
Exciting, exciting.
We have a very cute...
and fun show prepared for you guys so um and silly very
silly so um please look forward to it yippie yippie yippie
ungabunga green women yeah i'm excited i'm excited yeah i'm
excited uh i don't remember what else i was gonna say but
thank you guys for bioshock today and we'll do bioshock
saturday and i how far do you think i am in the game i'm
just curious because i need to plan my schedule for next
week too and how many bioshock streams i need to do before i
beat game faking it thank you one fourth oh shoot i don't
know if a 30 percentage oh yikes i wonder if i will be able
to beat it i might have to do like an endurance then.
I'm so slow.
Glad you're enjoying the game.
I've enjoyed being here watching you.
Thank you.
We have a good one and every wish for lots of love.
Thank you, Arjun.
Thank you.
You're about one-third of the way through.
Okay.
Exploring is cool, though.
This is how you enjoy games.
And honestly, yeah, I'm pretty...
I'm pretty slow with games but I do it's kind of how I enjoy
them too have a good night Mickey thanks for the stream hope
you feel better soon thank you Krona thank you so much thank
you thank you taking the pictures took a bit it did it did
that's true you're at a good pace it's a long game I thought
I would be okay because I think I remember saying seeing
that it was like a 12 hour average well how I don't remember
well that's okay we won't rush it we won't rush it if i
don't beat it before japan that's okay it's not ideal
because i don't want to like have to wait such a long time
in between i'll forget exactly i'll truly forget how to beat
everything so
but you can do it i'll do my best i'll do my best you got a
good system down after you warmed up again that's true that
is true saturday i think saturday and then i think i have a
for Tuesday.
I can probably fit it in twice again too before I leave.
Or something.
Probably.
Okie dokie.
You're slow because you save every five seconds.
I know.
But that's not why I'm slow.
Saving takes five seconds.
Thank you guys!
Alright so we talk!
Have a good day, have a good night and I'll see you next
time I'll see you!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye Bye bye bye bye bye Bye
bye I was talking but I didn't have my mic on and you guys
missed my whole song
I was talking I was saying, oh my gosh guys the game didn't
crash today but my mic wasn't on okay okay you can't just
revive OBS yes I can okay let me sing it again hold on let's
redo wait wait I started the beginning guys the game didn't
crash today oh my gosh we made it the whole time and the
game The game didn't crash The game didn't crash The game
didn't crash The game didn't crash The game didn't crash The
game did not crash The game didn't crash The game did not crash